bonjour à tous et merci de nous
retrouver sur Public Sénat à suivre ce
matin les auditions de Michel Boyon
l'ancien président de l'Agence française
de lutte contre le dopage de David
douiller médaillé olympique et ancien
ministre des sports ainsi que de
Jean-Pierre monddenard médecin des
sports et spécialiste de la question du
dopage ils sont entendus par la
commission d'enquête sur la lutte contre
le dopage qui a été spécialement créé
pour apprécier l'efficacité de la lutte
contre le dopage alors en 2012
l'Académie nationale de médecine a
publié les résultats des 10511 contrôles
qui avaient été effectués 2 ans
auparavant par l'Agence française de
lutte contre le dopage sur plusieurs
sportifs de très haut niveau et selon
cette étude les infractions constatées
s'élèvent à un peu plus de 2 % un
chiffre sous estimé selon l'agence en
cause l'utilisation de produits dopan
spécialement conçus pour que leur
détection s'avère extrêmement difficile
voire impossible car ils correspondent à
des substances naturellement présentes
dans l'organisme c'est le cas des EPO ou
encore des hormones de croissance même
chose du côté du dopage par
autotransfusion lui aussi extrêmement
difficile du coup la législation
actuelle s'avère insuffisante pour
lutter efficacement contre le dopage et
il faut donc l'adapter aux nouvelles
technologie et modalité de dopage c'est
le cas notamment de la loi éthique du
sport et droit des sportifs du premier
février 2012 ou encore celle de 2008 sur
la lutte contre le trafic des produits
dopan qui vient sanctionnner la
détention la fabrication l'importation
et l'exportation de tels produits mais
sans plus tarder direction la salle
cléenceau pour ses auditions concernant
la lutte contre le dopage très bonne
matinée à tous sur Public
Sénat monsieur bonjour à nouveau et et
merci de de nous avoir
rejoint vous êtes le premier que nous
entendons dans le cadre de cette
commission
et je voudrais rappeler que cette
commission d'enquête a vu le jour à
l'initiative du groupe socialiste du
Sénat et à l'initiative en particulier
de Jean-Jacques lozac qui a été désigné
comme rapporteur de cette commission
d'enquête
je dois rappeler qu'une commission
fait l'objet d'un encadrement juridique
très très strict très
précis ainsi les personnes présentes
dans le public ne doivent en aucun cas
approuvver ou désapprouvver par une
manifestation quelconque leur intérêt ou
leur désintérêts pour les choses qu'ils
entendent je me do do aussi vous
préciser qu'un faux témoignage devant
notre commission
d'enquête fait l'objet de peine prévu
aux articles 434 13 à 434 155 du code
pénal sur la
base d'une peine d'emprisonnement de 5
ans et 75000 €
d'amende je dois aussi
euh vous demander monsieur de bondbart
de de monar de procéder à un sermenton
euh de dire toute la vérité rien que la
vérité levez la main droite et dire je
jure merci
euh je vous donne maintenant la parole
si vous le souhaitez pour une dizaine de
minutes un peu plus ou un peu moins
c'est vous qui jugerez de la longueur de
votre intervention
liminire et puis euh Jean-Jacques lozac
notre collègue euh moi-même nous
poserons si vous voulez bien quelques
questions donc nous vous écoutons
merci pour envisager le le dopage
aujourd'hui on ne peut pas se soustraire
de l'étude antérieure de ce qui s'est
passé depuis des siècles car le dopage
n'est pas eu une invention de 1998 et de
l'affaire Festina ça remonte à la nuit
des temps il y a quelques années j'avais
écrit un article et Dieu créal dopage
donc c'est pas d'hier et je vais passer
rapidement pour montrer que c'est ancien
et que ça concerne tous les
sports car c'est l'homme face à la
compétition qui est confronté au dopage
et non tel ou tel sport donc pour
montrer que c'est
ancien on remonte aux Jeux
olympiques antiques et on s'aperçoit que
le dopage est omniprésent
puisque 16 siècles avant
Jésus-Christ l'alcool est prohibé il y a
un juge qui est à l'entrée des stades
pour renifler laaleine des compétiteurs
et ceux effectivement qui sont épinglés
et bien doivent verser des amendes qui
vont servir à constru à construire des
statutes à la gloire des dieux de
l'époque 6 siècles entre 5 et 6 siècles
avant Jésus-Christ là on arrive vraiment
dans parce qu'à l'époque effectivement
il y a pas de médicament ce sont des
plantes ou alors on utilise le principe
de la consubstantialité qui consiste à
croire que les qualités d'un animal on
va les récupérer en mangeant leur viande
et donc Milan croton qui est
l'emblématique champion de cette
période mange en tout cas ceux de ses
ses collègues compétiteur mange de la
viande de porc chez les lutteurs les
lutteurs mangent de la viande de porc
les LAN
et boxeurs mangent de la viande de
taureau et bien sûr les sauteurs mangent
de la viande de
chèvre et ça paraît effectivement
anecdotique aujourd'hui mais je peux
vous dire que dans les années 80 il y
avait des clubs de rugby en
France les avants consommé du sanglier
et les arrières du chevreuil avant les
match donc tout ça voilà l'histoire
d'aujourd'hui elle a pris sa base il y a
très longtemps et à la même époque et
j'en aurais fini avec l'histoire
ancienne parce que là je pourrais vous
en parler pendant 3 jours à la même
époque les compétiteurs au 5e siècle
avant Jésus-Christ se présent
euh dans le l'environnement immédiat des
compétitions avec des nourrices qu's ont
à leur table et ils têtent le au sein
maternel le le lait car le lait de
colostrom qui est le lait de la fin de
la grossesse c'est du début euh après la
naissance de l'enfant ce lait contient
des anabolisants contient des facteurs
de croissance et donc il tête les noures
qui sont à côté d'eux lors des des
compétitions alors bien sûr les légendes
Astérix popeille et
compagnie mais mais là aussi il faut
savoir qu'en
1980 la France souhaitait le CNOSF
souhaitait prendre comme
mascotte
Astérix ils ont été obligés de ne
pas souscrire à cette idée en raison de
la relation avec la potion
magique donc là pour montrer que ça
toujours existé et c'est la nature
humaine c'est l'homme face à la
compétition qui va chercher un truc pour
battre son concurrent il n'admet jamais
que l'adversaire est plus fort que lui
il croit toujours qu'il a un truc de
plus donc il va chercher le truc alors
pour ensuite
aller dans l'histoire actuelle du sport
qui qui remonte à la fin
du du 18e et bien le premier article que
j'ai en français sur le dopage concerne
la montagne l'alpinisme alors qu'on nous
parle d'air pur de valeur et
CETA
était c'était une communication d'un
médecin le docteur marsey devant le club
alpin de Londres et sappelait des
stimulants alcooliques dans les courses
de montagne 1887
ensuite donc la montagne est concernée
par les les les drogues de la
performance on va pas vous faire un saut
on on va en 1908 au Jeux Olympiques de
Londres où un italien deorondau piéterie
au marathon
va s'écrouler dans le dernier tour 400 m
va le faire quasiment à quatre pattes va
être relevé par des officiels pour
passer la ligne et c'est ça qui va le
disqualifier et on va
apprendre par la chronique de l'époque
qu'il est stimuler aux drogues de la
même époque bien sûr la stricnine la
tropine qui vont effectivement devenir
des produits qui vont apparaître dans la
liste des substances interdites plus
tard pour dire donc le dopage a toujours
fait partie de la panoplie des sportifs
là on revient en France là on était en
Angleterre c un Italien et d'ailleurs on
se rappelle l'ensemble des historiens du
sport se rappelle de dorandoo pietter
mais pas du tout du premier parce qu'il
a été disqualifié et donc le premier euh
un américain John i euh plus personne
sait qu'il a remporté ce marathon par
rapport à la disqualification de son de
son vainqueur sur le moment on est en
1920 et là c'est une
française Suzanne langlen une joueuse de
tennis qui va être surnommé la divine
qui va être une star planétaire qui va
faire agrandir où il me le donne par
parce que les femmes à l'époque de
Suzanne langlen attiré plus de public
que les que les hommes
et cette femme donc en 1919 va remporter
Wim lon devant la tenante du titre à
l'époque ça s'appelait donc
les les concurrents passai les
qualifications pour aller en finale et
la gagnante de l'année précédente allit
directement en finale on appelait ça le
Challenge Round et donc elle rencontre
en finale une Anglaise qui a euh
remporté wmedon à plusieurs reprisesé 5
6 ou se victoires à wmedon et donc
Suzanne longlen qui a 20 ans euh va
battre cette cette anglaise mais ce qui
est important c'est ce que raconte la
chronique de l'époque
et au premier set elle gagne 9 set au
2uxème elle est en difficulté elle perd
46 mais dès le premier set quand elle
était en difficulté puisqu'elle gagne
que 97 quoi elle
était le le match est très euh comment
dire difficile pour elle et on voit
quelque chose surprenant qu'on verrait
plus aujourd'hui bien sûr son père qui
est son entraîneur sur le bord de du
cours va lui lancer un flacon de Cognac
et devant tout le monde devant les
régnants il y a le le roi la reine la
princesse mairie qui deviendra reen
ensuite va boire à la régalade son
flacon de Cognac elle va récidiver au 3è
set elle va gagner donc ce
match 10 46 et 97 et à l'époque l'alcool
le cognac fait partie de la pharmacie ou
de la panoplie des compétiteurs de
tennis puisqu'on verra beaucoup plus
tard Borotra qui jouait des tas de
matchs se sublimer au cognac aussi donc
l'alcool contrairement à ce qu'on peut
croire bien sûr l'importance c'est la
dose si vous prenez la bouteille c'est
pas terrible pour jouer au tennis il a
aucun sport mais si vous prenez une
faible dose c'est efficace la meilleure
preuve c'est qu'en 68 aux Jeux
Olympiques à Mexico le premier contrôle
antidopage de l'histoire des Jeux
Olympiques ils vont faire 668 tests un
seul positif ça va être un Suédois
compétiteur du pentathlon moderne et qui
va être pris à l'alcool la France va
récupérer la médaille de bronze puisque
la Suède va être déclassée la France
récupère la médaille de bronze et sur un
test et le seul test positif de ces Jeux
Olympiques va être ce test à l'alcool
parce qu'on interdisait l'alcool
dans deux spécialités dans le tir et
dans
l'esrime et donc parce que effectivement
faible dose ça améliore la précision du
du du geste
et pourquoi ça avait été introduit sur
cette liste alors c'est c'est l'anecdote
mais c'est quand même significatif c'est
que l'année d'avant au championnat du
monde en Autriche l'un des compétiteurs
qui avait pris de l'alcool puisque tous
prenaient de l'alcool avait tiré sur le
jury et donc le jury avait dit stop
l'alcool et voilà pourquoi c'est on
s'est retrouvé avec un cas positif à
l'alcool en 68 voà donc on a vu le
tennis dans dans le football nen parlons
pas le le dopage était était omniprésent
et et toujours il faut rappeler qu'en 58
il y a un footballeur professionnel de
Bologne qui va devenir médecin qui va
devenir président de la Société de
Médecine italienne médicosportive
italienne
euh
auutanau
euh qui va donc ce ce ce ce footballeur
devenu médecin va faire une étude en 58
sur les footballeurs de la série a
c'està-dire la première division 27
% le nom de ce médecin c'est gerérardo
Otani 27 % prennent des amphétamines 62
% prennent des stimulants du cœur et de
la respiration 68 % prennent des
stéroïdes anabolisants on est en 58 un
match par semaine
deux entraînements par semaine l'argent
il y en a beaucoup moins qu'aujourd'hui
donc là aussi c'est une constante c'est
pas l'argent qui fait le dopage c'est
l'ego la compétition tant qu'on n pas
intuité ça et bien on
parle comme un amateur qui connaît pas
bien le sujet le vrai moteur du dopage
c'est la
compétition le
football tout à l'heure on a on a parlé
j'ai parlé des stimulants dans les cours
de montagne mais il faut rappeler
également une part importante du dopage
dans les années 50 tous les 8000 il y a
14 8000 sur la
planète plutôt 12 excusez-moi et donc
les 12 8000 de la planète ont été
vaincus par des amphétaminés toutes les
pharmacies et les pharmacies
individuelles qu'ils amenaient au sommet
donc c'était pas pour leur faire prendre
l'air qui les amen au sommet contenait
toute la panoplie des
de l'époque donc les stimulants en
particulier parce que dans dans les
années 50 donc Herzog et lachnal quand
il monte la
naurna le 3 juin
1950 ils sont
amphétaminés les anglais alors chaque
pays parce que vous savezà l'époque
c'est une compétition on nous dit en
alpin il a pas de d'opage parce qu'il y
a pas de compétition c'est archifux à
l'époque c'est une compétition
internationale entre la France
l'Angleterre l'Allemagne l'Autriche les
Italiens pour conquérir un 8000 et même
on avait quand l'équipe de quand Herzog
et ses collègues sont allés à l'urna on
les distingué sous le sous la
terminologie d'équipe de
France et donc les Français utilisaient
le maxiton les Anglais la benzedrine les
Italiens le pervittin et les les
Autrichiens également le pèrevtin et non
les Italiens c'était la saamine et les
Autrichiens allemand le pervitin tous
des amphétamines et donc les
amphétamines ont commencé à pénétrer le
monde du sport à partir des années
50 l'alpinisme on a utilisé pas mal et
puis les autres sports également le foot
le
cyclisme alors la la deuxième donc là on
a vu que effectivement il y avait pas
que le le vélo qui était concerné par le
dopage puisqu'on croit qu'il y a que le
vélo qui est concerné est par le dopage
euh et je voudrais faire un aparté sur
le le
cannabis qui est considéré par certains
comme pas une drogue dopante par
d'autres comme une drogue dopante et euh
de deux élément pour faire votre
gouverne votre appréciation en
1960 il y a pas de lobbying antidopage
il y a pas de lutte antidopage VZ
vraiment en Italie un peu mais autrement
c'est pas le le le discours euh numéro 1
dans le sport et il y a il y a un livre
qui sort euh sur la corrida sur la
toromachie par un
spécialiste d'origine espagnole et il
sort son son bouquin en 1960 à la table
ronde et ça s'appelle des taureaux et
des hommes et dans ce livre il écrit que
le TA le tauréador le matador 30 minutes
avant de rentrer dans la Plaza fume un
joint de Marie Rana et en dessous il y a
un Astérix qui renvoie au bas de la page
Marie
Rana cannabis
doping donc il a lui en tout cas la
perception que le cannabis est pris en
tant que doping dopage puisqueà l'époque
on dit doping et dopage viendra un peu
plus
tard alors pourquoi le torero prend du
cannabis pourquoi il prend du cannabis
et bien parce que il va affronter une
bête de kg et le cannabis est un
désinhibant il va pas prendre du
cannabis pour taper à la course le
taureau il va pas prendre du cannabis
pour attraper le taureau par les cornes
et le mettre sur le dos il va prendre du
cannabis pour pas maollir face au
taureau et le cannabis pour moi est
fondamentalement une drogue dopante pour
la raison essentielle c'est que tout ce
qui agit sur le système nerveux central
est typsofacto indopan tout ce qui agit
sur le système nerve central et le
cannabis bien sûr agit sur système nerve
central car dans la dans la dans la
compétition le le mental joue un rôle
fondamental et donc beaucoup de
témoignages démontre que sous cannabis
alors qu'on dit vous avez les sportifs
on raconé pourquoi ils prennent du
cannabis en boîte avec un whisky est
évident qu'avec ça ça va pas marcher
mais si on prend dans un but d'pan à do
l'important c'est la dose un dose
adaptée le cannabis ça marche et
notamment les Gaules sont
très
accro du cannabis parce que eux ils sont
foncièrement agressés dans les stades de
80000 spectateurs par les le le le
groupe de de spectateurs qui est
derrière eux dans dans derrière les buts
et donc nombreux footballeurs ont été
épinglés avec du cannabis dans des
contrôles antidopages ces dernières
années voilà donc le cannabis pour moi
c'est un vrai dopan il agit sur le
système n central tout ce qui agit sur
le système n central
l'effet sera pas constamment le même
chez tout le monde mais il y a d'autres
drogues les amphétamine aussi tous les
tous les stimulants n'ont pas forcément
le même effet chez chez
chacun alors on va rentrer dans dans le
vélo parce que c'est quand même
important de voir l'évolution et le
comportement des dirigeants du tour de
France des fédérations parce que au
final moi ce que je vais vous dire c'est
que c'est ça ne peut pas marcher la lut
antidopage tant que les fédérations sont
à la tête de la lutte antiopage c'est
impossible est-ce que vous connaissez un
jury d'assise ou c'est la propre famille
du jury qui le juge est-ce que vous
connaissez un PDG délégué syndical et
bien là on est en plein dans ce système
c'est pas possible et donc en
55 sur les pentes du monventou c'est la
première fois que le Tour de France
passe par le Ventou il fait chaud ils
sont tous aux amphétamines et il y en a
un qui va s'écrouler jean-méjacques qui
a failli y rester il y a une enquête une
vague enquête qui est effectuée on vire
un soigneur et puis on repart comme
avant et on va se retrouver dans la même
situation que sson en 67 lui il va
mourir malheureusement l'affaire Festina
en 98 l'affaire Puerto en
2006 une affaire de plus à chaque fois
et ça change rien puisque tous les
éléments restent en place rien ne change
rien ne change peut-être les ministres
de temps en temps mais c'est tout rien
ne
change et donc après cette histoire Malé
JAAC le tour suivant vous voir que la la
ressource humaine pour trouver des mots
pour raconter pour faire faire plaisir
au public donc là on va nous vendre en
56 donc là cétait en 55 on va nous
vendre que le tour de la désintoxication
donc j'ai un article sous les yeux à la
fin de l'année 55 le cyclisme français
commence sa cure de
désintoxication donc on sait
pertinemment en 55 que tout le Ploton
marche aux hétamine et pourtant en
98 reprenez la presse le patron du tour
le patron de la
fédération en quelques jours j'en ai
appris plus qu'en 20 ans on on rêve on
rêve l'hypocrisie à ce point-là il faut
vraiment être sur le
podium bien sûr que tout le monde sait
que le dopage est omniprésent bien sûr
par exemple en en 65 l'un des patrons du
Tour parce qu'il a deux patrons du Tour
à cette époque
là jacqueset Félix Litan Félix
l écrit dans la presse en 65 avant la
loi qui va être voté le 1er juin écrit
dans la
presse ceux qui ne se do pas sont des
pauvr
types ils seront voués à l'échec et à la
défaite donc on apprend deux choses
c'est que le patron du Tour est pour le
dopage ce qui se DOP pas sont des
pootypes et deuxièmement que si on se do
pas on
perd deux
choses moi quand j'ai j'ai pénétré le
Tour de France parce que j'ai été 3 ans
dans le Tour de
France quand j'ai pénétré le Tour de
France il m'a pas fallu une semaine pour
savoir mais je savais déjà puisque
j'avais pénétré le cyclisme
professionnel un peu avant avant euh que
l'ensemble du Ploton médicaliser la
performance médicaliser la performance
ils prennent tous tous il y en a pas un
ils prennent tous des médicaments alors
il y en a qui sont dans la liste il y en
a qui sont desselables il y en a qui le
sont pas il y en a qui sont dopan mais
qui sont pas dans la liste ils prennent
tous des médicaments
pour pour médicaliser la performance
donc considère on considère
que la compétition c'est une maladie et
que l'on soigne cette
maladie donc les médicaments sont
omniprésents dans la panoulie d'un
sportif de de
compétition alors pour montrer la la
duplicité des des gens parce qu' c'est
c'est c'est c'est schizophrénique
l'histoire hein d'un côté ils
vendent du bonheur et donc il faut
occulter tout ce qui va dégrader l'image
et là j'ai un article sous les yeux en
58 pourquoi le tour le Tour de France
va-t-il de plus en plus vite en 58
pourquoi le Tour de France va de plus en
plus vite je peux vous le faire lire il
y a pas une seule fois le mot d'age pas
une seule fois et en même temps dans
d'autres
pages on
lit à JOINV donc fameux bataillon de
joville l'école de joville ESS un
antifatigue révolutionnaire
pour améliorer les performances vous
avez t ESS dans l'équipe l'équipe a
collaboré à participer copieusement à la
diffusion ou à l'idée de de prendre des
trucs vous avez en 58 toujours dans
l'équipe un fortifiant utile donc on on
fait croire au sportif qu'il a besoin de
prendre des trucs tout le temps toutes
ces publicités c'est ils ont besoin de
prendre des médicaments pour améliorer
leurs prestation donc on soigne la
compétition
ben donc le rédacteur en chef de la
rubrique cyclisme de l'équipe qui nous
dit que le Tour de France va de plus en
plus vite et à aucun moment il parle de
dopage à la même époque l'un des
journalistes les plus emblématiques de
l'équipe et du cyclisme pierre
Chani après le grand grand prixation 59
dit il y a 88 % des compétiteurs ils
sont 25 à peu près à avoir cour grandpr
des nations qui est une épreuve contre
la montre seu et il est prêt à donner sa
paye à la caisse de secours des
cyclistes professionnel s'il y en a plus
de trois qui n'ont rien pris et il dit
je suis sûr de conserver ma
pay toujours à la même époque là donc
Tour de France va de plus en plus vite
sans rien toujours à la même époque le
directeur
sportif de l'équipe de France Marcel
Bidau quelqu'un
d'intègre raconte
75 % des coururs du Tour se dopent et je
peux vous en parler en connaissance de
cause c'est lui qui parle c'est pas moi
je peux vous en parler en connaissance
de cause quand je fais les chambres le
soir et bien c'est ce que je
constate donc le le dopage est
omniprésent dès les années 50 60 70 et
ensuite on va arriver donc il y a déjà
un mort aux Jeux olympiques de 1960 Mar
Johnen dans le 100 km contre la monre
c'est une épreuve par
4leil il fait plus de 40 degr c'est à
Rome le 26 août et ce garçon au bout de
d'une vingtaine de kilomètr s'écroule on
le relève on le remet sur son vélo il
s'écroule de nouveau il est mort et
l'autopsie m qu'il a pris les
amphétamines donc ça ça va faire
effectivement un peuu les consciences
mais pas longtemps en 67 Simpson meurt
sur les PES du Ventou même
scénario il a pris des amphétamines
l'autopsie va le
démontrer l'étape est effectivement sous
la chaleur on monte le le Ventou qui est
un obstacle important donc le fait de
faire un effort ça surchauffe
l'organisme les amphétamines entraînent
une hyperthermie donc elles augmentent
la la chaleur du corps et tout ça fait
que effectivement ça entraîne un
collapsus c'està-dire un désamorçage de
la pompe et à ce momentl effectivement
rien est irgé et le le le cycliste meurt
mais alors personne se pose la question
personne j'étais le premier comment se
fait-il que Simpson meurt alors que
l'ensemble du pleloton carbure au même
produit personne se pose la question on
va dire qu'il était fatigué on va dire
que voilà il était pas en forme il
aurait pas dû faire le tour de France
en
réalité en dehors de l'effort en dehors
de la chaleur du du moment de la
température ambiante qui est autour de
40 euh on est en début
d'après-midi il a au pied du Ventou
comme d'autres ils se sont arrêtés dans
un
bist pour pour prendre des boissons
parce qu'à l'époque on n' pas le droit
de se ravitailler en dehors des postes
de ravitaillement donc on est obligé de
faire la chasse à la canette et c'est
après la mort de Simpson que ça va
changer qu' il va y avoir un camion
isotherme qui suit la course et on peut
se ravitailler en course maintenant on a
poussé le la la la la facilité à mettre
une moto fraîcheur c'est comme ça
qu'elle s'appelle où il y a des bidons
qui sont sur la moto et qui sont
distribués dans aux échappées ou voilà
et bien euh Simpson il rafle une
bouteille de CIAC et il en boie la
moitié et l'alcool est un diurétique
donc il a augmenté les effets d'léteres
des amphétamines de l'effort de la
déshyratation voilà pourquoi il y a un
mort alors que les autres ils ont pris
des boissons et quand vous êtes
déshydratés il faut avoir fait du vélo
pour savoir ce que c'est que la
déshydratation quand on est déshydraté
on boit n'importe quoi il y en a même
qui sont arrêtés dans des canaux
d'irrigation pour boire tellement ils
étaient déshydratés voà donc il boitent
et voilà pourquoi Simpson décède mais
l'histoire n'est pas
finie c'est que une semaine
après la mort de Simpson il y a un
contrôle c'est en 67 c'est la deuxè
année où il y a des contrôles 1ière
année 66 2è année 67 et ça c'est sous
les directives de la justice il y a un
Hissier un médecin mandaté c'est pas la
fédération qui est à la tête de
l'antidopage c'est la justice et deuxème
contrôle sur tour de France à Revel de
positifs donc au moment où Simpson meurt
tout le Ploton est effondré il pleure à
chaud de larme et cetera et bien 8 jours
après deux coureurs se font épingler
avec le même produit que
Simpson donc ça éclaire sur le
comportement des hommes de 20 25 30 ans
euh qui dans leur dictionnaire n'ont pas
le mot santé ça existe pas à 25 ans vous
savez pas que vous allez mourir la mort'
aucune signification la santé pas
beaucoup plus et donc de mettre des
choses dans son corps ça ça ça pose pas
vraiment de problème
métaphysique et donc ils ont quand même
pris la même drogue en prendant prenant
un
risque al il faut il faut rajouter alors
dès cette époque il y a quand même des
médecins qui sont pas complètement en
dehors de de de la plaque si on peut
parler vulgairement qui on qui ont
compris que c'était un problème de santé
publique puisque il y a un des médecins
du tour le le docteur Robert Boncourt
qui va faire un article en 1960 parce
que dans 1960 il y a un Français qui
chute dans un col des sevenes colle de
de perjuré au-dessus de
mot et qui qui se fracture la colonne
vertébrale et qui va disparaître de la
circulation cycliste qui va mourir à 40
ans et qui était une star en devenir
énorme puisque il avait déjà été
plusieurs fois champion du monde
poursuite il
avait fini 4e du Tour de France
59 qu'il avait battu le record de l'URE
à deux reprises et ce ce garçon donc va
devenir même
toxicomane en prenant un antalgique le
palphium et on dit la la chronique de
l'époque raconte que c'est parce qu'il
avait il était sous
palfium pour supporter les douleur
intense quand vous êtes au maximum à
vélo et que dans la descente de ce
fameux col il a cru freiner il a pas
freiné il est passer par
parap voilà donc
et ce médecin d'effroyable danger menace
la vie du champion Koba transform en
champion suicide et on apprend occasion
il a un journaliste qui rentre dans la
chambre futur vainqueur Nini qui va
mourir à 49 ans de
cancer est dans sa chambre avec une
perfusion dans chaque bras il a une
cigarette aux lèvres et s'en soigneur à
côté qui lu retire la cigarette pour
enlever la cendre il lu ré la cigarette
parce qu'il a les deux bras prisonniers
par ses perfusions et dans les
perfusions il y a des anabolisant des
corticoïdes on est en 1960 et un médecin
avec l'équipe Carpano il fait partie de
l'équipe Carpano c'est l'équipe d'Italie
mais il y a un médecin d'équipe Carpano
qui est là donc de nous faire croire en
98 que l'organisation du dopage d'une
équipe c'est une
nouveauté c'est une
hypocrisie de nous faire croire que le
les anabolisants les corticoïdes sont
apparus dans les années 7 et plus tard
c'est une
hypocrisie la lutte antiopage et le le
le le dopage sont encombrés d'hypocrit
et il y a même un un soigneur qui disait
de prendre des
euh anabolisants ou des dopants l'effet
secondaire numéro 1 c'est de rendre
hypocrite en
63 il y a il y a un colloque alors
effectivement ça bouge la la il y a des
morts devant la télévision Simpson il y
a il y a des d'autres cas le le Danois
aux Jeux olympiques mais il y en a
d'autres il y a deux jeunes qui vont
mourir en 68 un footballeur et un
cycliste l'autopsie
amphétamine donc il y a eu une autopsie
là on a trouvé les amphétamines de
jeunes qui meurent dans la région de
Grenoble donc tout ça effectivement ça
ça remue les consciences notamment
politique mais la première loi va être
donc
l'inspiration à l'instigation de Maurice
Herzog le paradoxe c'est que lui il
avait priseamphétamine pour monter en
haut de la lapurna et qui va donc faire
voter cette loi
en 65 le 1er juin 65 et là aussi c'est
une information pour tous ceux qui
lisent la presse française c'est que
c'est pas la première loi au monde elle
est la première loi antiopage elle date
du 1er avril 65 2 mois avant et ce sont
les Belges qui ont été les premiers
à promulguer une loi contre le dopage
mais malheureusement pendant un an on
peut rien faire puisquil y a pas de
décret d'application il faut attendre le
10 juin 66 pour qu'il y ait un décret
d'application donnant la liste des
substances interdite et là elle est
intraduisible la liste et je me suis
amusé parce que moi je suis arrivé dans
dans le dans le système au début des
années 70 au tout début des années 70
donc il m'a fallu quand même j'ai le
dopage j'ai fait des contrôles dans dans
en province dans la France prof
et même un journaliste avait écrit dans
l'équipe qu'il fallait correspondant de
guerre pour faire des contrôles à
l'époque j'ai un confrère qui a été
tabassé poursuivi en bagnole sa voiture
dans le fossé lui et sa compagne ont été
tabassé ça s'est term en justice il
exerçait à Bordeaux et bien il a
poursuivi sa carrière en
Bretagne donc pour vous dire qu'il
fallait vraiment avoir envie de faire
des contrôles antiopage
et donc
euh les voilà donc je je je reviens pour
l'histoire de de de la loi qui est le
décret d'application et dans ce décret
d'application il y a la liste des
substance interdite et donc quelques
années après j'ai questionné le patron
du laboratoire en lui demandant à quoi
ça
correspondait le dialcool amide des
acides alcool aminobutyrique
il a pas pu me répondre il a questionné
tous ses
confrères il savait pas et voilà c'était
ça la liste donc
intraduisible même par des spécialistes
voilà donc effectivement on on
s'aperçoit en tout cas la la conclusion
que j'en j'en ai la perception que j'en
ai c'est que d'un côté vous avez des
professionnels du sport qui font du
sport et en face vous avez des amateurs
qui luttent contre
eux et donc la la liste et donc j'ai
j'ai j'ai trouvé bien sûr à quoi
correspondait ce ce ce produit à
rallonge la dénomination chimique
c'était c'était le micorè peu importe ça
c'est l'anecdote mais c'est pour montrer
que effectivement rien n'était fait dans
un
sens vraiment éducatif et compréhensible
et de de mettre re le le flou dans dans
dans le la
réglementation c'était pas la bonne
tactique et autre chose là aussi que
vous allez apprendre alors que la loi
date de 65 c'est que ça jamais été une
loi antidopage si vous prenez le journal
officiel du 1er juin 65 c'est une loi
antitimulant c'est marqué en toute
lettre antitimulant pourquoi et ça aussi
c'est important pour
l'avenir bien à l'époque on est en 196
65 la communauté scientifique croit que
le
dopage ce ne sont que les
stimulants et en même temps vous avez
dans les revues de médecine la revue de
médecine éducation physique et sport qui
est la revue de médecine du sport
d'aujourd'hui qui est donc la la la
revue officielle de la société française
de médecine du
sport propose à ses médecins donc dans
les années 60 vous avez la publicité le
Durabolin pour vos sportifs prescrivez
le Durabolin qu'est-ce que c'est le
Durabolin c'est la nandrolone qu'est-ce
que c'est que la nandrolone c'est le
stéroïde anabolisant qui va être utilisé
pendant les 40 années suivantes le plus
par le les sportifs qui se dopent c'est
un stéroïde anabolisant et donc en 60 on
dit au médecin du sport prescrivez les
stéroïdes anabolisants et on bien sûr à
l'époque mais ça ne concerne pas que le
dopage vous prenez le Vidal le le
dictionnaire des
j'ai tous les vidales depuis que
j'exerce donc j'en ai un paquet et mais
je peux vous dire jqu'au milieu des
années
80 j'ai même le premier Vidal de 1914
j'étais pas là bien sûr euh qui qui est
un petit bouquin comme ça
euh si vous prenez le Vidal vous prenez
chaque notice des médicaments et bien
vous avez les effets à quoi ça sert la
la posologie euh comment ça fonctionne
et jamais un effet secondaire jamais un
effet
secondaire reprend jamais un effet
secondaire donc là pareil pour les
stéroï Anapolis on dit au médecin et au
sportif prenez des des stéroïdes
anabolisant alors un intérêt parce que
par exemple on VI on vient d'apprendre
que Oscar Pistorius
l'Américain l'Africain du Sud
qui a qui a assassiné sa sa compagne
était était sous l'emprise de stéroïde
anabolisant et les stéroïdes
anabolisants effectivement entraîne ce
qu'on appelle la rage des stéroïdes
c'est sous stéroïd anabolisant devient
hyper violent on passe par des phases
hautes et des phases basses psycloimique
mais d'une violence extrême he ce qui
explique que effectivement comme les
anabolisants sont très répandus dans
certains sports tels que le football
américain le ho sur
gllace d'Amérique du Nord où il y a même
par équipe un méchant qui est qui est
spécialement entraîné AC le méchant qui
fait 130 kg la plupart du temps qui est
pourourri d'anapolisant d'agressivité
qui est chargé de descendre les
meilleurs de l'équipe d'en face mais
tout le monde le sait tout le monde
l'admet tout le monde continue à aller
voir les les les compétitions et donc
c'est sous les stéroïdees
anabolisant que l'on arrive
à ce genre de de réaction et d'ailleurs
dans la la publicité des années 60 et ça
pendant 25 ans la communauté
scientifique a l'oublié dès le départ le
laboratoire sait que ça entraîne des
effets de ce genre puisque vous avez sur
la notice la publicité du produit action
psychotonique puissante alors
psychotonique ça veut rien dire pour
personne et c'est ça action
psychotonique puissante c'est
agressivité maximale
pour bien montrer parce que j'en ai vu
défiler des des ministres au fil du
temps et leur connaissance sur le dopage
était vraiment très limite et après
l'affaire Vestina il y a une ministre
qui qui se répondait que le dopage
allait aller toucher les les jeunes les
amateurs moi quand je rentre dans le
milieux sportif de haut niveau en 70 le
dopage touche les
amateurs et meilleure preuve c'est qu'au
premier pas d'unlope 68 1 an après la
mort de Simpson 1 an après la mort de
Simpson le médecin du Tour de France qui
n'est pas duuma qui n'est plus duuma
parce qu'il a perdu sa place à la suite
de la mort de Simpson he il y a eu
quelqu'un qui a qui a perdu dans
l'affaire la lutte antidopage a rien
fait mais le Dumain a perdu sa place et
donc au au prier pas lope c'est un
championnat des des jeunes et
sur six contrôles C positifs alors vous
allez me dire vous êtes en train de nous
dire que le contrôle il ép pas grand
monde et d'un are côté là
effectivement dans dans le sport amateur
les contrôles sont tellement rares que
personne croit qu'il va être contrôlé un
jour alors que effectivement dans le
monde professionnel de faire un contrôle
après une compétition c'est une perte de
temps et d'argent car le jeu c'est de
passer à travers le contrôle donc là
aussi tant qu'on continuera à faire les
contrôles après les compétitions on perd
son temps ça ça fait du bien aux
fédérations ça fait du bien aux
organisateurs car ils disent regardez on
a fait 150 contrôles zéro positif pas de
dopage c'est extraordinaire tout le
monde se se félicite mais moi je suis
patron d'une entreprise qui me raconte
que 180 150 contrôles tous négatif je
les vir tous je dire c'est que vous êtes
mouvis voilà donc donc les contrôles à
postériori c'est une perte de temps et
d'argent et le gouffre que cela entraî
rendez-vous compte et c'est pas moi qui
le dit là effectivement j'ai dit ça
depuis très longtemps hein depuis la fin
des années
70 et que les contrôles c'est c'était
c'est un contrôle négatif n'était jamais
la preuve de l'absence du
dopage et et donc récemment David Oman
le directeur général de de l'Agence
mondiale antidopage un néozélandais
ancien compétiteur de tennis
euh a fait une conférence devant
l'UNESCO à
l'Unesco en novembre 2011 donc il y a
pas longtemps quoi 2 ans
et pas tout à fait et donc euh David
Oman raconte qu'ils ont fait
255000 et des poussières test dans
l'année 2010
qu's ont attrapé épinglé 36 le PO et
conclusion le le lutte antidopage et
pathétique le patron de Lama qui dit ça
la première fois qu'un responsable de
l'antidopage
admet qu'ils sont pas très performants
qui sont pas très
performants alors autre élément c'est
qu' aucune lutte antiopage possible il
aucune lutte antiopage possible s'il y a
des substances
indessolables c'est pas
possible c'est comme les radars si on
dit aux gens tel endroit il a des radars
c'est pas très performant et bien de
faire un contrôle antidopage postérior
c'est de dire il y a un
radar et le jeu c'est de passer à
travers le radar et les possibilités de
passer à travers le radar es sont
multiples donc les seul contrôle qui ont
une valeur à mon sens sont les contrôles
inopinés à
l'improvise sont les seuls les autres
c'est de le le gouffre des Danaïdes le
tonau des Danaïdes au niveau de
l'argent ça ne sert à
rien puisque les hommes il faut rappeler
aussi un truc il va faire plaisir à
personne mais c'est c'est comme
ça c'est que la la triche le mensonge
c'est consubstantiel à l'homme
c'est consubstantiel à l'homme toutes
les enquêtes le montrent au moins 60 %
dans toutes les activités humaines
triche toutes les enquêtes donc c'est
pas ça qui me choque c'est pas
qu'Armstrong et remporter 7 tours de
France à la barbe de la lutte antiopage
c'est pas ça qui me choque qui triche
c'est humain ce qui me choque c'est
qu'on verse des sommes pas possibles
pour attraper des gens et on attrape
jamais personne en tout cas pas quand il
faut c'est ça qui me choque hein puisque
la nature humaine c'est de mentir de
tricher plus que de dire la vérité et de
jouer le jeu dès l'enfance les les tout
jeunes il jouent au au jeux de loi il
joue au petits chevaux il
trichent regardez il trichent ils
veulent gagner c'est dans la nature
humaine après l'éducation va plus ou
moins mais quand vous rentrez dans le
sport de haut niveau
et bien la
compétition qui commence suivant les
fédérations de plus en plus jeunes et
bien c'est l'école de la triche on va
vous apprendre à gagner et c'est pires
le footballeur pires qui racontait que
domneek qui avait été son entraîneur
quand il était en équipe de France des
jeunes lui avait appris à tomber dans la
surface de réparation pour obtenir un
penalty
Dominque avait appris à tomber
pour obtenir un pénalty donc la triche
c'est consubstantiel à l'homme tant
qu'on n pas intégré
ça on navance
pas accepteriez-vous que l'on passe à la
phase de
question à nous dire parce que j'ai j'ai
écrit 4000 pages sur le dopage 1000
articles 1000 articles dans la la presse
scientifique dans la presse médicale
dans la presse sportive don
effectivement c'est un sujet que je
crois connaître et et donc effectivement
mais moi en venant ici c'est c'est pour
au maximum vous faire percevoir que la
lutte antiopage c'est pas celle que vous
lisez dans les journaux et que le dopage
n'est pas ce que vous lisez dans les
journaux et c'est pas le monde du sport
qui va vous apprendre ce qui est le
dopage c'est pas le monde de
l'antidopage qui vous apprendre ce qui
est age parce que chacun veut paraître
plus beau qu'il ne l'est donc il va
vendre sa soupe en disanton vous voyez
on épingle que quelques cas c'est que on
est efficace on en est pas il y en a pas
beaucoup c'est que il y a pas beaucoup
de
dopage je peux répondre à vos
questions merci
pour l'ensemble des choses que vous AZ
pu nous dire jusqu'à présent je demande
à Monsieur le rapporteur de vous d'être
le premier à vous poser quelques
questions oui merci euh monsieur
monsieur le Président et merci à à
Monsieur demandenard pour je dirais ce
double regard le regard à la fois
médical scientifique et puis d'autre
part le regard historique mais justement
sur cet aspect historique depuis la loi
de de 1965 que que vous avez rappelé
est-ce que quand même il y a eu des des
moments des périodes des des dispositifs
des des textes adoptés qui ont permet
d'être qui ont permis d'être plus
efficace dans cette lutte antidopage que
d'autres est-ce a eu un certain moment
des des avancées et si oui lesquelles ou
bien est-ce que on en est un peu dans la
situation des des années 70 des années
des années 80 deuxièmement est-ce que
vous avez le sentiment en terme de santé
publique que les produits qui sont
employés qui sont utilisés sont de plus
en plus dangereux ou pas pour les
utilisateurs les consommateurs et qui
sont à la fois des représentants de du
sport amateur et du sport professionnel
comme comme vous l'avez dit et enfin
également sur ce registre là puisque
notre notre objectif vous l'avez bien
compris c'est d'essayer de de faire des
propositions pour être plus efficace
dans cette lutte antidopage que
pensez-vous des des modalité de
fonctionnement et et des moyens d'action
qui sont aujourd'hui ceux de l'Agence
française de la lutte contre le
dopage aux trois questions mais je vous
demanderai là je vais répondre à la
première je vous demanderai de
reformuler quand j'aurais répondu à la
première la deuxème et puis la 3è
voilà alors est-ce que la lutte
antiopage a fait
progresser la lutte est-ce que les
moyens mis en place ont fait progresser
la lutte alors le premier constat que
que je fait ça fait 40
ans le premier constat que je fais c'est
que effectivement la lutte antilopage a
progressé mais ça a professionnaliser le
camp d'en face et donc ils sont de plus
en plus
performants il y a toujours des
substances indéelables et je le répète
tant qu'il y a des substances
indéelables vous ne pouvez pas lutter
efficacement contre le DOP alors il y a
eu des avancées parce qu'effectivement
il y a une prise de
conscience par exemple Maurice Herzog
que que j'ai eu à plusieurs reprises au
téléphone parce qu'il a fait la préface
de mon dictionnaire du
dopage me disait que sa lutte antidopage
sa loi antidopage n'avait servi à rien
et
al alors il avait pris conscience au
bout d'un d'un certain temps parce que
pour une simple raison sa sa loi
antidopage ne n'avait pas pu aboutir
puisquelle elle ne pouvait pas entraîner
de sanction dans la mesure où il fallait
démontrer que le sportif avait consommé
siamment le produit donc ils avaient
tout de suite trouvé la parade un avocat
un peu futé leur avitessoufflé tu dis
que on t'a passa un bidon sur le bord de
la route et que tu ne savais pas que
dans le bidon il y avait comme quoi les
les spectateurs ont tous avec eux des
amphétamines à mettre dans le bidon ou
des produits d'pan pour les passer au au
sportifs donc
les les comment
dire les gens qui ont été pris lors de
ce premier tour de France contrôlé en
66 n'ont pas été sanctionné il faut
rappeler quand même que en 66 année des
premiers contrôle il y a 12 coureurs
contrôlés 6 positifs ce qui fait en
clair 50 % du Ploton est positif l'année
suivante il y en a 12 % l'année d'après
il des poussières l'année d'après 4 % 4
% et en 70 il a une remontée à 10 %
alors il y a toujours une explication à
tout c'est quand 70 on a réajouté
l'phédrine qui est un stimulant qui
remplace les amphétamines et
effectivement il ils étaient pas bien
informés qu'il avait cette effédrine et
ils se sont fait épingler et ensuite on
est arrivé vers 1 2 3 % et la lutte
antiopage s'est gargarisé en disant
voyez 50 % au début alors sur l'ensemble
c'était 32,5 % les Tours de France 50 %
et donc tout le monde s'est gargarisé en
disant voyez la lutte antidopage est
efficace il y en a de moins en moins non
première chose c'est qu'ils ont ils se
sont pointés au contrôle
avec des flacons d'urine vierge d'un
d'un d'une personne dans l'encadrement
ils arrivaient avec le flacon d'urine
dans la poche et il le versait dans
le flacon test et donc ils étaient pas
épinglés sauf une fois où l'un des des
concurrents néerlandais Carsten avait
demandé à son mécanicien la fameuse
urine de remplacement et pasatra qui
s'est retrouvé positif parce que
effectivement le mécanicien lui aussi
s'était dopé pour le conduire jusqu'au
départ de la course et il a perdu une
grande classique le Tour de Lombardie
sur ce le contrôle de son mécano voilà
voilà
donc première étape pour contourner le
contrôle ils arrivent avec une
de remplacement 2ème étape ils vont tous
dans les substances indessolables et dès
les années 60 vous avez un article dans
la République des Pyrénées donc un petit
journal local le journaliste raconte que
la lutte antidopage n'est pas pertinente
puisque il y a des substances
indessolables et donc à partir de là
tant qu'il y a des substances alors bien
sûr il y a eu des avancées on a trouvé
d'autres produits laffire Festina par
exemple a boosté la recherche on a
trouvé le PO on a trouvé les PFC on a
trouvé les hémoglobines de synthèse on a
trouvé les corticoïdes mais en 97 en
97 l'année avant l'affaire Festina le
laboratoire de antidopage des chevaux
euh parce que depuis plusieurs années je
disais c'est quand même pas normal que
chez les chevaux on trouve les corticoïd
et chez l'homme on les trouve pas donc
effectivement ça ça a fait bouger un peu
le le ministère des sport et donc ils se
sont rapproché du laboratoire des
chevaux et ils lui ont demandé de tester
les urines du Tour de France 3e semaine
du Tour de France 80 % du Ploton est au
corticoïde qui est interdit bien sûr qui
sont interdits voilà et Fignon dans sa
biographie qui dit à mon époque on
pouvait pas se doper car tous les
produits étaient dcelables et quelques
pages trois pages après il dit on
prenait tous des corticoïdes parce
qu'ils étaient delable donc il a même
pas relu son bouquin ou il a même pas lu
peut-être et il disait l'inverse de ce
qu'il avait dit quelques instants avant
donc à partir du moment où vous avez des
substances indcel vous pouvez faire
toutes les réglementations les lois ça
marche pas et bien sûr il y a eu
non de que que la lutte devienne
internationale que l'Agence mondiale
antidopage soit créée mais d'un autre
côté il faut quand même rappeler et là
je vais pas faire plaisir encore à
beaucoup de
monde c'est que les gens qui sont nommés
à la tête des des agences qu'elle soi
internationale comme l'agence
monantidopage
ou qu'elle soit nationale la veille bon
c'est une expression mais ça ça traduit
correctement ce que je veux dire la
veille ces gens-là ne savent pas si
dopage prend un P ou de Pai et le
lendemain ils sont interrogés par les
journalistes comme des experts je l'ai
vécu dans des émissions où la personne
patron d'une agence répondait sur les
dangers d'un produit et la veille il
était président du d'une radio je sais
pas quoi attendez qui peut croire une
seconde qui peut croire une seconde au
message de ces gens-là c'est pas
possible
pour parler de l'Agence mondiale
antidopage le premier patron de l'agence
antiopage mondiale c'est dig pound un
ancien compétiteur des années 60 qui qui
a fait de la la natation qui a été en
finale
olympique avocat
ensuite et qui effectivement nayant pas
obtenir la présidence du CO on lui a
donné comme bâton de maréchal la
présidence de l'agence mondale
antidopage et qui est dig pound vous
rappelez qu'en 88 il y a un célèbre
athlète Ben Johnson qui se fait épingler
à sou au 100 m qui est l'avocat de Ben
Johnson dig pound et qu'est-ce qu'il
veut démontrer à la planète que Ben
Johnson ne s'est pas dopé que sa tête
était pas dopée son corps oui parce
qu'on lui avait mis un produit dans son
bidon voilà donc comment voulez-vous
qu'elle soit crédible il y a deux
personnes au monde à ma connaissance qui
sont crédibles et elles sont jamais à la
tête de l'antidopage il y a un Italien
sandR
Donati qui a mis à
jour les activités perverses de
Francesco cononi un italien qui a été le
l'instigateur du dopage à leepo dans le
sport
mondial qui était encore alors que ça se
savait qui était encore comme membre de
la commission médicale du CU mais
comment quand on est vraiment quand on
lit les choses correctement et qu' on
lit tout ça on dit mais qu'est-ce que
c'est que ce ce foutoir c'est pas
possible et bien oui il était membre de
la commission médicale du CIO le fameux
Conconi donc le Sandro Donati et qui a
fait tomber aussi Ferrari un autre
médecin qui avait oublié le serment
d'Hippocrate et un Allemand vernerard
franque qui a mis à jour tout le dopage
d'Allemagne de l'Est qui s'est appuyé x
procès contre les sportifs de haut
niveau qu'il a mis en cause donc qui ont
affronté les menaces et physiques qui on
et ces gens-là ils sont pas dans la
lutte antidopage internationale voilà
donc
euh il y a effectivement des avancé mais
ça va tellement lentement que le camp
d'en face il est toujours en avance de
plusieurs trains et donc c'est pas euh
très euh performant alors j'ai pas
besoin de la deième question
je je
réponds le danger des
produits alors ça aussi c'est une c'est
un mode de communication actuel des
journalistes en
particulier qui
pour
limiter leur complicité passive et pour
se redorer leur image nous raconte
depuis quelques années que avant à
l'époque où il suivait les courses
le dopage était ridicule et les
performances
maximales et aujourd'hui le dopage
extraordinaire et les performances
ridicules donc de nous faire croire que
les sportifs d'aujourd'hui sont des sont
des moins que rien style depuis l'ffaire
Festina Armstrong Mme on présente
Armstrong comme un coureur de de niveau
inférieur mais non Armstrong a été le
meilleur courur de sa génération il a
battu les meilleurs qui étaient tous
préparés de la même façon
regardez Jalabert quand il répond à ce
moment-là il dit bien pour moi alors
tout le monde parle d'Armstrong comme un
pseudoch champion mais Jaber il dit mais
non Armstrong c'était un super champion
pourquoi il dit ça parce que avec les
mêmes éléments biologique l'utre le
battait et pas d'un peu donc Armstrong
c'était vraiment mais c un voyou c'est
un voyou mais c'était un très bon
coureur il avait
organiser son son système c'est pas le
quand le tigart le fameux avocat de de
l'usada du sad de la l'agence américaine
antidopage qui voulait la poîte au prix
d'Armstrong qui s'était moqué de lui X
fois raconte que c'est le dopage le plus
sophistiqué de l'histoire du sport là
aussi c'est une imposture lui même après
son son audience là la télévision va
raconter
que il avait le même dopage que ses
adversaires que le dopage qu'il
utilisait c'était quasiment le même que
celui de l'Allemagne de l'Est dans les
années 80 et moi avant qu'il sorte ça
dans dans les médias j'avais expliqué
qu'effectivement le dopage d'Amstrong
n'avait rien de différent à celui de de
virinque il utilisait de PO de la
testostérone des corticoïdes l'hormone
de croissance rien de nouveau pas les
dopages génétique annoncé et cetera il
utilisit le même dopage sauf que
Armstrong c'était une entreprise et
comme tous les Américains l'objectif
c'est de gagner et donc il avait mis
tout en place pour que ça gagne il
s'était rapproché de mers il avait
compris au contact de mers que il
fallait avoir une équipe avec des des
gens dans son équipe d'un très haut
niveau des vainqueurs potentiels il
avait des vainqueurs potentiels du tour
dans son équipe é à son service vous
savez quand vous êtes dans la roue d'un
pleloton ou de quelques cyclistes vous
économisez 33 % d'énergie donc il se
faisait tirer pendant 220 km 200 km il
était dans la roue de ses coéquipiers et
lui s'appuyait le dernier col quand tous
les autres étaient bien entamé donc il
avait bien compris le système il
utilisait ça aussi l'organisateur est
totalement responsable ça aurait pas
existé avant du temps de Lévitan du
temps de desgrangees il avait un
hélicoptère à sa disposition privé qui
en haut des étapes d'altitude où les
autres mettaient 2 heur pour intégrer
leur hôtel il gagn 2 heur de
récupération et ça ça vaut tous les
dopan de la terre tous les dopan de la
terre donc voilà le système Armstrong
mais en aucun cas c'est un cycliste de
bas niveau
et c'est le dopage le plus sophistiqué
de la terre
voil les dangers des produits il y a pas
de
différence entre les amphétamines les
corticoïd le PO les anabolisants tous le
leurs cargaison d'effets secondaires on
a appris vous savez que les amphétamines
au départ les laboratoires en faisait la
publicité dans les roues médicales pour
combattre la somnolence au volant Paron
disait que la somol volant
tué bien je peux vous assurer que les
phétam elle tue encore plus que la
somolance au volant parce que elle vous
donne le grand volant c'est-à-dire vous
n'avez plus la la maîtrise de l'espace
vous croyez invulnérable et dans le
virage au lieu de tourner et bien vous
allez direct dans le Platan et
d'ailleurs la mortalité des cyclistes
j'ai fait une étude sur les cours du
Tour de France avec l'Institut Curri
avec d'autres personnes et qui ont
montré que l'accidentologie cycliste des
cyclistes professionnels était nettement
plus élevé que la moyenne européenne
quasiment euh multiplié par 2 elle était
d à à deux raisons c'est que il pédalent
sur les routes donc ils sont euh
plusieurs heures par semaine 20 25
heures par semaine sur les routes à vélo
et que le vélo n'a pas de pare-choc et
deuxièmement ils prennent des
amphétamines pour conduire pour aller de
de de course en course à l'époque en
tout cas dans les années 80 90 et ça ça
entraîne aussi des une accidentologie
importante donc au niveau de dire aussi
euh là aussi c'est un un moyen de dire
qu'aujourd'hui les substances sont très
dangereuses voilà pour renforcer le fait
que on lutte contre quelque chose euh de
plus en plus important non les les les
amphétamines entraînai aussi des des euh
des fibrose vasculaire donc les les les
accidents cardiaques pareil dans cette
étude sur le Tour de France euh entre 25
et 34 ans les courur du Tour de France
dans les années
70-90 mourit cinq fois plus d'accidents
cardiovasculaires que la moyenne
européenne qui boit qui mange pas
forcément régime sportif qui
fume cinq fois plus les cour du jour
d'fance meurent d'accident
cardiovasculairire entre 25 et 34 ans là
où on meurt rarement d'accidents
cardi-ovasculaires donc tout ça montre
bien que le danger il est il est lié à
la pratique sportive
intense par
exemple Jean-Paul art pendant les 25
dernières années de sa vie consomm une
vingtaine de comprimés de corydran qui
est une amphétamine associée à
l'aspirine le seul effort qu'il avait à
faire
c'était d'aller à sa cafetière si il aim
le café de se lever de temps en temps de
son bureau pour prendre un dictionnaire
vérifier un mot ou aller chez le
buraliste chercher son paquet de de
tabac et il prenait 20 20 comprimés de
de corydran j'ai pe- dit 25 tout à
l'heure c'est 20 comprimés de corydran
une amphétamine si vous donnez et il est
mort à 75 ans la moyenne de l'époque si
vous prenez si vous donnez ces 20 comp
de coridr un sportif qui monte le
Ventour au minimum il est en réanimation
au maximum il est à la morgue donc c'est
l'effort qui potentialise les effets
secondaires des
produits
l'effort est un est un élément délétaire
sur les produits donc de dire oui le PDG
c'est ce qu'ils disent comme excuse oui
on interdit pas au PDG d'aller à son
conseil
d'administration parce qu'il est grippé
prendre des produits non c'est que quand
on est sportif si on prend des produits
on prend un risque
supplémentaire et puis il faut savoir
aussi que les produits entraînent des
effets
thatogènes qu'est-ce que c'est que les
effets teratogènes sont des
effets qui apparaissent à la naissance
et qui sont induits pendant la grossesse
par la
consommation de la mère souvent mais du
père aussi et donc on est et les
enfants naissent avec
des ce qu'on appelle des des faomel ils
ont la la main qui est implantée à
l'épaule des pieds beauau et ce il y a
des déformations et au moment du procès
de l'Allemagne de l'Est de nombreuses
athlètes sont venus revendiquer ses
effets secondaires et être
indamnisés pour ses effets secondaires
liés au dopage donc les les produits
dopan que ce soit les amphétamines les
anabolisants le PO l'hormone de
croissance ont tous une quiirielle
d'effets secondaires qui n'ont rien de
sympathique merci pour ces réponses il
reste une question je demande au
rapporteur de la
reformuler une réponse rapide de votre
part nousveau elle portait simplement
sur les les les moyens d'action les
moyens de fonctionnement qui aujourd'hui
sont ceux de l'Agence française de lutte
contre le dopage pour voir si
effectivement il était possible ou
souhaitable d'améliorer son efficacité
actuelle et puis en fait une question
plus plus globale est-ce que vous pensez
que les les médecins généralistes par
exemple sont suffisamment engagés dans
cette lutte contre le dopage les
fédérations sportives l'encadrement
immédiat du du Pr il peuent pas être
plus engagés puisquil ils connaissent
pas la plupart les sportifs savent ceux
qui produisent qui donnent les produits
ou les programmes maintenant les
médecins savent très bien que c'est
dangereux de prescrire des produits
dopan il risquent ils prennent des
risques donc il ils assurent le le les
protocoles donc c'est le sportif qui
se ravitaille par Internet par par des
circuits annexes et euh le le médecin
qui donne les les protocoles qui
organise
les les protocoles en ce qui concerne
l'Agence française de lutte contre le
dopage on l'a bien vu avec Pierre
bordri qui est
parti la veille et il disait que la
lutte antidopage était efficace qu'il y
avait peu de sportif d'pé que les
substances indécolables étaient
quasiment toutes trouvées et il donne sa
démission et de jours après dans le
monde il dit l'inverse il dire il y a de
plus en plus de sportifs d'opé il y a de
plus en plus de substances indéolables
je peux vous renvoyer les les articles
concernés donc donc il faut que cette
agence soit vraiment indépendante et
alors je sais pas qui qui la nomme qui
qui
intervient euh voilà de toute façon dans
dans les dans les propositions que je
feraiis la première la la la première
avant toutes les autres c'est de retirer
la lutte antiopage du monde sportif ce
n'est pas possible ce n'est pas possible
vous pouvez pas d'un
côté vouloir obtenir un maximum de
médailles et de l'autre empêcher les
gens d'avoir des
médailles c'est impossible ça fait 40
ans que ça dure 45 ans c'est pas
possible tant qu'on reste et le système
fonctionne depuis
1965 le système ne marche pas depuis
1965 et on continue là c'est pas
possible il faut que la lutte antiopage
sorte du monde sportif il faut également
qu' ait un laboratoire
antiopage indépendant alors pour pour
créer une indépendance ça c'est c'est
pas ma je veux dire j'ai pas la
formation pour savoir comment on arrive
à créer un système indépendant en tout
cas il faut créer un laboratoire
indépendant qui soit exclusivement
orienté vers la recherche pour trouver
les substances que les sportifs
utilisent parce qu'on arrive à un
paradoxe mais qui dure depuis 65 les
sportifs prennent des substances que les
laboratoire ne trouve pas et laboratoire
recherche des substances que les
sportifs ne prennent pas donc c'est pas
possible c'est pas possible il faut
vraiment aller à ce niveau et puis
dernier point mais il y en a d'autres
parce que j'étais un peu long bien sûr
dernier point il faut qu' aussi que les
tribunaux que les juges comme il y a des
juges antiterroristes il faut qu'il des
juges antidopag des juges qui
connaissent la question parce qu'il y a
trop de gens qui sont passés à travers
la
justice et qui étaient des vrais dopeurs
et qui continuent à
exercer parce que la justice n'était pas
assez efficace pour les mettre hors
d'état de
nuir merci pour ces réponses je demande
à François Pilet de poser la dernière
question oui vous m'avez beaucoup
inquiété lorsque vous avez beaucoup
insisté sur le fait que la triche c'est
consubstantielle à l'homme c'est pas
très très optimiste et je me dis que si
vous avez définitivement
raison la lutte contre le dopage est à
vitam etnam perdu mais alors pour pour
me donner encore un peu d'espoir
j'essaie de faire une distinction
c'est-à-dire entre celle celle entre le
sport spectacle bon s'il est perdu il
est perdu mais le sport santé je pense
en particulier au plus jeunes sport
amateur au jeunes adolescents est-ce que
vous pensez que enfin quel est votre oui
votre pensée face à l'utilisation de
plus en plus courante de produits de par
pharmacie les cocktails de vitamines les
boissons énergisantes que on voit
circuler dans les clubs d'adolescents
est-ce que c'est pas
l'apprentissage ou la banalisation d'une
future
performanceû
les les publicités dans les revues
sportives on voit le champion avec la
boîte à côté de lui et donc ça ça ça
veut dire que c'est grâce à la boîte
qu'il est devenu champion ce que
contient la boîte donc tout ça ça pousse
toutes les revues sportives ont des
publicités de ce genre et donc elles
poussent à la consommation et donc à un
moment donné donc ils sont jeunes
effectivement ils prennent des
vitamine et puis ensuite l'entraîneur
leur donne leur dit mais non en comprim
mais ça marche pas il faut en piqûure
alors peut-être dans la piqûure il y a
toujours des vitamines et puis après qui
est autre chose le sportif pas faire la
différence donc voilà
l'engronnage démarre dès que l'on prend
des produits pour soigner la performance
les vitamines ça se prend pas pour une
compétition les vitamines ce sont des
des cures éventuelles par rapport à des
carences éventuelles mais on prend pas
des vitamines pour un match quand un
sportif vous dit qu'il prend des
vitamines pour un match il il vous il
vous il vous balade car il y a aucune
vitamine si on prend bien le mot
vitamine dans son sens exact il y a
aucune vitamine qui booste la
performance aucune
pardon oui oui mais ça aussi la la
publicité il faut vendre donc on sort
des des termes qui sont pas forcément en
rapport avec la la réalité du produit en
tout cas partir une vitamine une vraie
vitamine les vitamines du groupe A B C
ce sont pas des vitamines qui boostent
la performance par exemple on va prendre
le Guronzan le Guronzan contient quoi la
vitamine
C l'acide glycuronique qui est un
détoxicant et de la caféine voilà le le
produit boostant c'est pas la vitamine C
donc on on vous met en avant la vitamine
C et et autre chose là on nous parle de
dopage depuis 2004 l'agence mondal
antidopage a retiré la caféine de la
liste et la caféine c'est un produit
dopant depuis
des siècles c'est un produit dopan les
sportifs l'utilisent en injection en
comprimé c'est un produit dopan il a des
études encore récentes qui ont montré
chez le footballeur que ça améliore la
précision du tir que ça améliore la
détente verticale on se fiche du monde
quand on me parle de lutte
antidopage merci Daniel Michel peut-être
ce qui sera vraiment la dernière
question oui moi ce qui m'interroge le
plus c'est la responsabilité des
médecins comment peut-on être médecin
avoir prêter serment et puis administrer
à des à des jeunes des produits dont on
sait qu's auront des effets néfastes sur
la santé alors effectivement les les
médecins sont
forcément un rouage important dans la
pérénisation du dopin eu
et malheureusement les les médecins
avant d'être médecins sont des hommes
les les journalistes avant d'être
journalistes sont des hommes et dans le
milieu sportif et notamment lorsqu'il y
a une
médiatisation leur objectif principal
c'est d'être l'ami du champion c'est
d'être le parrain du fils du champion
c'est d'être à la table du champion vous
allez dans leur cabinet il y a les
photos des Champions avec eux mais que
ça soit les médecins que ça soit les
soigneurs que ça soit les journalist que
ça soit tout le monde il y a des
journalistes également qui participent à
des séances de dopage avec les sportifs
et c'est eux qui vont ensuite critiquer
le dopage dans le dans leur journaux
c'est l'homme l'homme qui soit médecin
qui soit journaliste qui soit avocat qui
soit tout ce que vous voulez il voilà
c'est toujours la valorisation de sa
situation et donc des vous savez qu'il y
a des des médecins notamment un médecin
qui était un médecin
d'opeur confident de plein de champion
mais il s'est fait enterré avec le
maillot de l'un de ces
sportifs merci je suis désolé de
jouer à l'arbitre au senseur me dit mon
rapporteur merci beaucoup pour ce que
vous nous avez
dit permettez-nous de vous dire que si
nous avions besoin de tel ou tel
documents vous vous auriez bien sûr
l'amabilité de nous les transmettre sans
problème merci beaucoup au
revoir
d'accord
merci
de nous avoir rejoint et d'avoir
acceptter de venir devant cette
commission
d'enquête je ne sais pas s'il faut dire
monsieur le député monsieur douillet
monsieur le champion olympique monsieur
le champion du monde
le ministre monsieur le ministre
j'allais finir par ça mais merci
monsieur le rapporteur de m'indiquer ce
que j'avais
oublié cette commission d'enquête a été
constituée à l'initiative du groupe
socialiste
et notre rapporteur Jean-Jacques LOAC
est aussi au sein de ce groupe à
l'origine de cette commission d'enquête
command il s'agit d'une commission
d'enquête je suis désolé il y a un
encadrement juridique très précis
et
j'indique ce sont les même que ceux qui
ont assisté à la première audition toute
manifestation est impossible de la part
du
public pour approuver ou désapprouver ce
qui serait avancé par la personne que
nous recevons je précise aussi à
l'attention de Monsieur douillet que les
personnes i ne doivent pas faire faux
témoignage devant notre
commission cela serait pasible des
peines prévu aux articles 13413 à 134
155 du code pénal en résumant 5 ans
d'emprisonnement et 75000 €
d'amende c'est le tribunal qui
déciderait je vais aussi vous demander
de prêter
serment tout simplement de de nous dire
la la vérité toute la vérité et de le
faire en levant la main droite euh en
disant je le
jure merci monsieur le sénateur euh
d'abord je trouve que cette commission
ah faut d'abord dire oui do commencer
alors je je jure de dire toute la vérité
rien que la vérité merci on vous écoute
euh oui donc je disais d'abord merci de
de de de me faire l'honneur de d'être
auditionné pour cette commission
d'enquête que je trouve nécessaire voilà
déjà je trouve nécessaire parce
que il y a et on l'a encore vu
dernièrement encore beaucoup de progrès
à faire sur ces sujets hein je vous fais
pas je fais pas l'article sur ce qui
s'est passé
notamment des révélations qu'on qu' pu
faire l' Armstrong par exemple euh mais
mes propos je vais essayer de les faire
les plus courts possible parce que vous
êtes déjà très informé sur ce que je
vais vous dire mais je tenais à faire un
un un recadrage parce que N surtout sur
le plan international parce que tout à
l'heure à travers vos questions
j'essaierai d'élargir sur peut-être
d'autres d'autres visions et des sujets
qui sont communs et qui commencent à
naître sur la la scène internationale
sportive donc a on on assiste depuis les
années 2000 à une vraie organisation de
de la lutte contre le lopage à l'échelle
du monde au niveau
international d'abord la création en en
1999 de l'AMA l'Agence mondiale
antidopage vous le savez bien c'est une
organisation internationale
indépendante qui est composé et financé
à parial par le mouvement sportif et les
gouvernements des États la main
coordonne et supervise le développement
et la mise en place du code mondial
antilopage dans la première version dont
la dernière version date de 2007 on
attend une prochaine version euh
avec beaucoup d'empressements en 2015
bon
elle aide à à harmoniser les règles qui
sont liées au dopage dans tous les
sports et dans dans tous les pays en
tout cas les pays qui
sont signataire il y en a
150 c'est une convention
qui permet de de de respecter les
principes du code et les standards qui
lui sont
associés la France a ratifié cette
convention en
2007 c'est une convention internationale
contre le
dopage dans le sport euh au niveau
national l'Agence mondiale antidopage
donc elle s'appuie sur des agences
nationales malheureusement pas dans tous
les pays concernant la France vous le
savez il s'agit de la FLD aujourd'hui
qui a été créé en en 2006 le 5 avril euh
la FLD qui
euh dans la perspective d'un d'un d'un
rapprochement avec les statut présidés
préconisés par l'Agence mondiale
antidopage fa d succès la fois au
conseil de prévention et de lutte contre
le dopage auquel j'ai j'ai eu cet
honneur de de siéger en tant qu'athlète
représentant des athlètes qui à l'époque
était une simple autorité administrative
je crois que vous avez auditionné
monsieur Bryon ce matin c'était le
président à l'époque lorsque je j'y
étais
euh et
euh une simple autorité administrative
adossé au au Laboratoire national de
déction de dopage le LND de chatenem
àabri établissement public classique et
euh au ministère chargé des sports pour
ses attributions dans la définition de
la stratégie des contrôles antiopages et
de l'organisation
euh les principes fondamentaux de la
lutte contre le dopage en France s
appuyé sur euh plusieurs choses d'abord
la notion de justice sportive si un
sportif participe à une compétition en
ayant eu recoi des substances ou
procédés de nature à modifier ses
performances il s'expose à une sanction
disciplinaire de par sa fédération
d'abord ou administrative si la lfeld le
le le le le décide parce qu'elle en a
l'autorité il y a ensuite un dispositif
pénal qui a été adopté par la France le
3 juillet 2008 la loi relative à la
lutte contre le trafic des produits de
Pan
euh ce qui permet d'organiser la lutte
contre le trafic des produits de Pan en
pénalisant la détention de ces produits
mais aussi leur fabrication leur
importation leur exportation ou leur
transport légalise et favorise également
l'échange d'information entre les agents
relevant notamment du ministère des
Sports de la FLD ou de la police
judiciaire
ou et des douanes euh les récents textes
de
loi la loi du 21 juillet 2009 portant
sur la réforme de l'hôpital et relative
aux patients à la santé et au territoire
et ordonnance du 14 avril 2010 relative
à la santé des sportifs on permis de
mettre en conformité euh des
dispositions du code du sport euh avec
celle du code mondial antidopage qui a
été révisé en 2007 et entré en vigueur
le 1er janvier
2009 enfin la loi d'éthique du sport et
droit des sportifs du 1er février 2012 a
élargi la prérogative les prérogatives
de la FLD notamment en matière de
coopération
internationale à cette époque en tant
que ministre j'ai voulu que ce texte
soit un leviier pour étendre les
pouloirs de la FLD notamment en lui
permettant d'effectuer des contrôles
lors des compétitions nationales ce
déroulant d'athlètes français sur les
compétitions internationales se dou se
déroulant à
l'étranger et en renforçant aussi la
coopération avec les organismes
internationaux de la lutte contre le
dopage à cette époque ce texte était
déjà passé au Sénat avant que je sois
ministre et je m'étais efforcé à ce
qu'il soit voté conforme à l'Assemblée
nationale pour qu'il puisse être mis en
vigueur mais je vous avoue que en tant
que si j'avais été en fonction plutôt
euh j'aurais renforcé ce texte voilà je
vous le dis euh j'aurais été plus loin
mais les choses ont fait que euh le
temps m'était compté alors juste un
petit euh un petit euh Laus sur les
difficultés les limites de la lutte
contre le dopage
euh l'Académie nationale de médecine a
publié en courant 2012 des résultats euh
des 10511 contrôles effectués par les
FLD euh en 2010 alors ces contrôles
concernent 85 % des sportifs de niveau
professionnel ou pas participant en
compétition au niveau national ou
international le nombre d'infractions
constaté s'élève à 2,3
%. alors d'après l'Académie s résultat
sous-estime sans doute l'étendue du
fléon et on peut imaginer que ce soit
vrai effectivement compte tenu des
révélations que l'on a régulièr ement de
part et d'autre dans certains sports
dans le monde entier alors les
difficultés auquelles sortent
aujourd'hui cette lutte contre le
dopage relève évidemment sur la nature
des produits dopan et les modalités de
les modalités même de la lutte contre le
dopage le problème c'est que et vous le
savez bien ils ont toujours un coup
enfin les tricheurs ont toujours un coup
d'avance et profitent malheureusement
de milliards et de milliards de dollars
investis dans l'industrie pharmaceutique
classique pour soigner des citoyens
lambda profite de cette puissance là à
des fins pour travestir hein les les
molécules trouvées à des fins pour
améliorer les performances sportives
donc la lutte est compliquée parce que
quand on voit les montants investis euh
pour lutter contre ce fléo par rapport
au montant investi par l'industrie
pharmaceutique au sens large euh
évidemment il y a un déséquilibre
colossal colossal et on peut
s'imaginer tout bêtement que ce
déséquilibre persistera malheureusement
toujours voilà d'ailleurs je fais une
aparté c'est une des raisons pour
lesquelles à l'époque où j'étais
représentant des athlètes au conseil de
prévention et de lutte contre le dopage
euh j'avais on avait déjà constaté ça on
le savait déjà on le voyait déjà
et j'avais souvent dit on on ne faisait
que de la répression que de la
répression que de la répression bien sûr
qu'il en fout bien sûr c'est le c'est le
voilà c'est le fil rouge de l'histoire
mais nous ne faisions à l'époque
quasiment pas de prévention voilà le PAI
de prévention n'était pas
suffisamment acté en tout cas était pas
n'était pas suffisamment mis mis en
route voilà et je trouve que ce P de
prévention il est aussi pour moi aussi
important
que que le l de lutte à l'époque et
encore aujourd'hui voilà on fait pas
suffisamment de prention prévention les
gens sont pas au courant et en
particulier les parents voilà je pense
qu'on y
reviendra suffisamment tout à l'heure
dans vos
questions donc des accords ont été
conclu entre l'Agence mondiale
antidopage et cette industrie
pharmaceutique alors ça permet ça
devrait permettre en tout cas aux
organisations nationales type la FLD
d'être informé de manière précoce sur
les nouvelles molécules
euh et est-ce qu' est-ce qu' et surtout
ce qu'elles sont susceptibles d'induire
pour améliorer la la performance
sportive
alors toutefois ces ces accords là
n'apportent pas de
réponse sur les travaux des petites
entreprises de
biotechnologie il y en a beaucoup dans
le monde entré qui sont souvent parfois
victimes de de de de fite malgré malgré
leur souci de de confidentialité et pour
finir quelques petites quelques pistes
d'évolution euh alors dans la loi du 12
mars 2012 euh pour faciliter
l'organisation euh dans le cadre de
faciliter c'était le cadre de la loi
l'organisation des manifestations
sportives et culturelles j'ai réussi à
mettre là à ce moment-là j'étais venu
ici au Sénat d'ailleurs la mise en place
en tout cas la préfiguration du
passeport biologique qui est déjà en
exercice au sein de l'Union cycliste
internationale depuis 2008 un passeport
un passeport
biologique qui va permettre qui permet
qui permettra d'établir les paramètres
urinaires et sanguins de chaque athlète
pour avoir plus de plus de proximité
euh je vous ai parlé tout à l'heure de
la la nouvelle version du code
montiopage qui est largement attendue
pour
2015 elle devra inclure la possibilité
de renforcer les sanctions appliquées
aux sportifs et on été condamnés pour
pour
dopage notamment par l'interdiction de
participer aux Jeux Olympiques qui
suivent leur suspension par
exemple pour information dans un rapport
qui a été publié le le 20 juin 2012
encore une fois l'Académie nationale de
médecine formule notamment de deux
recommandations qui qui me semblent
plutôt bonnes à de mieux connaître les
accidents de complication médicales lié
à la pratique de pente
elle réclame cette académie que tout
décès observé sur les terrain de sport
soit suivi d'une autopsie je trouve que
c'est bien voilà c'est important il faut
qu'on sache la
vérité et d'ailleurs il y a eu des cas
assz dernièrement de footballeurs sont
morts sur les terrains
encore et elle préconise aussi également
la la modification de certaines
dispositions du Code monel antideopage
en vu d'une part de limiter la
compétence des fédérations
internationales aux seules grande
manifestation Sportiv de renom et
d'autre part d'alléger le calendrier
sportif ça c'est un vrai sujet aussi à
prendre en compte j'y ajouterai aussi la
problématique des jeux et paris sportif
en ligne voilà et pourquoi je vous ai
parlé pourquoi j'ai voulu faire un petit
rappel sur l'Agence mondiale sur le côté
international de la lutte contre le
dopage c'est que vous le savez bien
l'laesp le dit
aussi les mafias qui agissentant qu'il
dit ce sont les les enquêteurs les
spécialistes les mafias qui sévissent
dans le milieu du dopage sévissent de la
même manière sont les mêmes dans le
milieu des de la tricherie sportive de
la corruption sportive voilà et c'est
pour cette raison et j'en terminerai
là-dessus c'est pour cette raison que
lorsque j'étais ministre j'ai MRE
confidentielle
eu un entretien avec Jacques ROG
où je lui
indiquais ma vision des choses
d'ailleurs en
mutualisant deux organismes en
un à partir de ce postulat où on a de
une une un banditisme un grand
banditisme enfin en tout cas des une
organisation mafieuse qui SVIT dans les
de milieux nous devrions
urgemment à l'échelle du monde créer une
agence de régulation mondiale des jeux
paris sportifs en ligne c'est la même
c'est la même mécanique c'est la même
c'est la même façon de faire que pour le
dopage d'accord pour que des pays
puissent rapidement comme nous n l'avons
fait concevoir des lois pour que pour
aider les les enquêteurs pour aider à la
à la la
répression et mais aussi pour avoir des
moyens pour faire de la prévention de
mutualiser l'Agence mondiale antidopage
et cette agence de régulation mondiale
aussi de la corruption sportive de la
mutualiser pour ça coûte un peu moins
cher évidemment et faire en sorte que on
agisse là aussi sur la corruption
sportive qui induit aussi indirectement
ou qui motiverait la prise de produits
illicit en tout cas le dopage dans
certains
endroits dans certaines
compétitions euh pour avoir une lutte
plus efficace c'est beaucoup plus
puissante
voilà merci je
vais demander à notre rapporteur s'il a
des questions je pense que oui onrais
lui confier la parole pour quelques
minutes bien merci monsieur le Président
bon monsieur le ministre vous avez tout
à fait compris je dirais l'état d'esprit
qui était le nôtre en mettant en place
cette commission d'enquête parlementaire
et qui est d'aller vers des propositions
des propositions en direction de des
pouvoirs publics en direction de de
l'État en direction du mouvement sportif
aussi en direction de tous les acteurs
concernés par cette lutte antidopage
notamment le le secteur médical et puis
les les encadrements notamment technique
bref tout l'environnement de du du
sportif du sportif de haut niveau donc
toutes les les propositions qui nous
sont formulées sont effectivement les
les bienvenus mais une une première
question qui est un petit retour sur
votre votre je dirais sur votre passé
personnel puisque avant d'être ministre
avant d'être parlementaire vous avez été
un sportif de de très haut niveau
champion du monde champion olympique
euh est-ce que pendant justement ces
années de pratique à un moment ou un
autre vous avez été confronté à cette
pratique du dopage est-ce que vous
pensez que le judo par exemple fait
partie des sports épargnés j'ai j'ai
sous les yeux une une intervention de
quelqu'un vous connaissez très bien sans
doute Jean-Paul coche qui se disait à
l'époque étonné par l'état de de
surexcitation des des judocas des
anciens pays de l'Est une fois qui
quittait les les tatamis donc est-ce que
vous avez eu à à prendre connaissance à
un certain moment de ce type de de
pratique de de triche de de corruption
dans dans ce sport qui est votre domaine
de prédilection à savoir le judo
deuxièmement sur la lutte antidopage on
sait très bien qu'on est dans une sorte
de de course contre la montre une sorte
de course pours suite entre entre ces
laboratoires de de contrôle d'analyse
qui alimentent justement les les trafics
puisqu'il s'agit bien de de trafic de de
drogue de produits dopans et puis
d'autres et donc qui aliment toutes ces
filières des des irréductibles du sport
donc est-ce que vous avez est-ce que
vous pensez quand même que cette course
contre à la monte est en train de de
donner des résultats est-ce que on est
en train de de se rapprocher d'une
situation où les progrès dans cette
lutte sont débouch sur des résultats
sensibles il y a d'un côté ceux qui
effectivement trichent utilisent des
produits difficile à détecter voir
actuellement encore indétectable et puis
d'autre part des structures des
politiques publiques qui essaie
d'enrayer tout ça est-ce que vous sentez
que je dis pas qu'on s'approche de
l'éradication mais est-ce qu'il y a des
progrès significatif dans cette
lutte merci monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur le ministre
alors pour ce qui est
de à l'époque moi j'ai connu j'ai eu
enfin comme Jean-Paul coche d'ailleurs
qui lui a connu toute la enfin que que
des enfin l'époque du bloc de l'Est hein
moi j'ai connu la transition je suis la
génération qui suit enfin même deux
générations qui suit après Jean-Paul et
euh alors c'est c'est étonnant j'ai j'ai
pu j'ai pu voir les
l'explosion des du bloc de l'Est en
direct de la vivre en direct au cœur des
pays et et et nous avions athlètes des
relations très proches les uns les
autres puisque on les soutenait on les
aidait bon bref donc des des vraies
relations amicales entre les entre les
athlètes c'est vrai à l'époque à
l'époque et eux même le disaient il y
avait un dopage d'État point c'est que
les athlètes n'avaient pas le choix les
athlètes de l'Est n'avaient pas le choix
il y avait un dopage d'État d'organisé
bon euh à
titre personnel euh approché non jamais
entendu un certain nombre de personnes
dans d'autres disciplines en France oui
avec des personnes ciblées qui à
l'époque se faisaient étai clairement
des ce qu'on appelle des dealers oui en
tout cas une j'en ai une dans dans dans
dans la tête oui oui ça oui approcher
pourquoi non en judo parce que on a eu
cette chance d'avoir un un
d'ailleurs il est toujours en enfin
c'est toujours la même politique une
politique médicale assez stricte
c'est-à-dire
que l'organis à partir du moment où on
gère en permanence les athlètes
contrairement à d'autres sports qui sont
gérés les athlètes sont sont plus pris
en main par les clubs que par la
Fédération voilà c'est ça tout tout le
truc il est là quoi en fait vous coupez
court à laavenue de gourou de dealers de
de gens qui viendrai vendre leur
cochonneries ou en tout cas tenter les
athlètes pour qu'ils puissent à un
moment donné se doper je m'explique
c'està-dire que
la la main mise et c'est et c'est
bénéfique la main mise du corps médical
de la Fédération française de judo était
telle sur les athlètes que je dis était
parce que je peux pas parler de l'époque
d'aujourd'hui jusqu'en 2000 donc était
tel
que ça on avait un dô protecteur quoi
voilà c'est dire que notre médecin de
tous les jours que ce soit pour un rum
pour n'importe quoi c'était le médecin
de l'équipe de France nous devions à
l'époque lorsque nousous faisions nous
moi je m' arrivé assez fréquemment c'est
pour ça je vous parle du nez aujourd'hui
c'est pas pour rien je souvent rumé bon
à chaque fois je faisais faire une
j'allais voir un autre médecin ailleurs
quand j'étais en vacances à chaque fois
je faisais contrôler et d'ailleurs bien
m'en appris parce que plusieurs fois il
y avait des produits des colutoires
notamment qui étaient positifs euh parce
qu'il y avait de l'efférine ou je ne
sais quoi dedans hein à l'époque euh
parce que ce qui est efficace quand on a
la rume bah tout est positif donc je
faisais contrôler mes ordonnance en
permanence par le médecin de l'équipe de
France voilà parce qu'il y a une liste
incroyable de de de de médicaments donc
on était éduqué on a toujours été éduqué
pour ça pour vérifier faire vérifier nos
ordonnances lorsque nous voyons euh à
l'époque d'autres médecins c'est ce qui
nous a protégé
euh vous pourriez me poser la question
comment vous avez fait pour gagner face
à des athlètes
DEP bah la chance si j'avais fait du 100
m j'aurais jamais gagné quoi que ce soit
je peux vous le dire je pense que si
j'avais fait du vélo de la même manière
la chance qu'on a dans le judo c'est
qu'il y a énormément de paramètres qui
vont bien au-delà du physique pour
pouvoir gagner un combat de judo voilà
et que pas suffisamment en tout cas les
performances physique en tout cas les
capacités
physiques n n'ont pas une incidence
suffisamment forte pour systématiquement
permettre un athlète de gagner voil si
vous êtes pas capable de déclencher le
bon mouvement au bon moment vous avez
beau faire 300 kg en développer coucher
je dis n'importe quoi ou ou courir le
100 m en 6 secondes ça ne changera rien
il faut avoir et puis si vous avez pas
la technique le beau geste et ce ça
changera rien non plus bon voilà tout ça
fait que on était on arrivait quand même
à tirer not force de constater que
souvent euh malheureusement moi je je
j'assistais je voyais des choses
incroyables et il m'est arrivé de perdre
face à des gens où je me dis voilà c'est
pas possible quoi et et c'est
décourageant moi je m arrivé en poid
lourd donc
voilà face à un athlète russe en tout
cas de l'Union soviétique à l'époque qui
je vous raconte l'anecdote père
tenez-vous bien euh plus de 10 kg parce
qu'il est malade soidisant
malade donc passe des lourds en
lourd donc il est malade l'excuse invoqu
mais il fait quand même les games à
l'époque et gagne en pour quelqu'un de
malade c'est quand même assez
particulier et quelques mois plus tard à
peine un an plus tard je le retrouve en
lourd avec 10 kg
retrouvé
moi vous savez j'ai passé des heures en
salle de musculation et Dieu sait si je
m'en souviens parce que j'aimais pas
trop ça je vous l'avoue et vous savez
pour gagner ne serait-ce que quelques
kilos et quand je dis quelques kilos
c'est 1 2 3 kg de masse musculaire je
vous assure qu'il faut en passer des
heures en salle de musculation hein pour
gagner à peu près 2 3 kg de masse
musculaire de viande il faut s'entraîner
au moins enfin quasiment tous les jours
euh et et quasiment sur une
année récupérer 10 kg en moins de 6 mois
pour moi c'est impossible voilà les pèes
de les récupérer c'est impossible de
muscles hein on parle de musclle hein
voilà donc quand vous êtes athlète et
que vous voyez ça vous assistez à ça il
y a des fois où et que vous faites
battre par ce genre de personne c'est
compliqué c'est pour ça que pourre
étendre un peu ma
réponse j'ai en tête une athlète
française qui a qui qui vient arrêter sa
carrière et qui a été la troisème
meilleure performeuse mondiale de tous
les temps devant elle il y a deux
personnees qu'on fait mieux qu'elle il y
a Florence criffit joyer décédé très
brutalement très
jeune j'irai pas plus loin et puis il y
a Marion Jones
convaincu de dopage elle a avoué bon je
me dis quoi
elle elle a jamais pu je pense qu'elle
est c'est une athlète qui est propre
cette Française réellement je la connais
j'en suis quasiment convaincu j'ai pas
la pruve absolue mais j'en suis qu'ement
convaincu on lui a volé toute sa vie
c'est ça la vérité on lui a volé c'est
une
escroquerie on lui a volé de l'argent on
lui a volé des médailles on lui a volé
sa la vie d'athlète c'est du vol c'est
scandaleux c'est pour ça
que je vous disais tout à l'heure j'ai
pas été assez loin mais moi au fond de
moi je vous le dis ceux qui trichent et
je l'avais déjà dit à l'époque lorsque
j'étais au conseil de prévention et de
lutte contre le dopage je trouvais que
les peines infligées était un peu
légère je pense qu'il faut c'est comme
pour la prévention routière il faut
taper fort il faut taper dur un athlète
qui est convaincu de dopage une fois ok
premier premère avertissement mais il y
en a pas deux il devrait pas y en avoir
deux parce qu'ils veulent la vie d'un
autre et il met en danger la
sienne et de condamner aussi durement
ceux qui font partie évidemment du
système d'approvisionnement et cetera
mais si déjà on tap fort sur l'athlète
c'est un athlète qui vous le dit hein là
je vous parle en tant qu'athlète je
pense que déjà on fait réfléchir on
ferait réfléchir beaucoup de gens
c'est-à-dire que première sanction une
sanction suffisamment significative
deuxème sanction radié à vie radié à vie
c'est la seule manière de de de faire
prendre conscience à des personnages qui
peuvent être fragilisés par la fatigue
de l'entraînement par par la conception
de la réussite d'une vie par leur
jeunesse qui voilà il faut savoir qu'un
athlète est très protégé et dans une
bulle très jeune peut être manipulé
quelquefois même et c'est assez facile
parce que avec la pression qu'il subit
pour un individu c'est une vie qui est
extrêmement dure psychologiquement
parlant donc voilà ça c'est c'est une un
de mes
avis sur est-ce qu'on est-ce que le le
le
dopage la lutte contre le dopage
fonctionne je suis plutôt un optimisme
de nature et je me dis
que nos résultats France en français
tant dans la natation qu'au niveau de
l'athlétisme progressant j'ai
l'impression que oui j'ai l'impression
que maintenant on gagne beaucoup de
médailles nous la France en natation en
atelé et c'est pas pour
rien je pense que nos athlètes sont
propres euh ils sont extrêmement
surveillés sont propres je connais
moi-même intimement le le directeur
technique national de la de l'athlétisme
qui est un de mes amis il me me le
confie il a des doutes sur certains et
d'ailleurs certains sont fait prendre
mais en tout tas de cause aujourd'hui
notre augmentation significative de de
médailles dans ces deux disciplines qui
euh voilà historiquement ont connu des
cas assezz assz important nous moi ça me
enfin je pense que effectivement la
lutte a marquer des points vis-à-vis de
ceux qui veulent
tricher donc il faut
continuer monsieur le rapporteur vous
avez d'autres
questions une question sur le
fonctionnement de l'Agence française de
la lutte contre le dopage qu'estceement
d'après vous les améliorations
susceptible d'être apporté à cette à
cette agence est- ce qu'il faut à vos
yeux d'autre part davantage
responsabilité responsabiliser les
fédérations sportives notamment en terme
de prévention surtout en terme de
prévention je suis complètement d'accord
avec vous monsieur le sénateur le PAI de
prévention n'est pas
suffisamment c'estàd que la
la la lutte est
tellement demande tellement de moyens
financier ça coûte tellement cher que
effectivement la la prévention empathie
for forcément et ça les
fédérations devrai prendre plus à bras
le corp ce ce PAI de prévention au même
tite que le CIO parce que la réalité
enfin ça n'engage que moi mais je trouve
que le CO est très léger sur ce sujet
comme d'ailleurs beaucoup
beaucoup d'organis d'organisateurs
d'événements tout à l'heure je vous
parlais de le fait de
pénaliser significativement certains
athlètes mais je peux vous dire que si
on avait le courage il faut aller
jusqu'au bout des choses il faudrait
pénaliser aussi pour que eux-mêmes
fassent régner la loi dans leur
compétition ceux qui organise les
événements vous vous vous ne pourrez pas
m'enlever de
la de la tête je vous je vous parle
franchement que les organisateurs de
trop de- France ne savaient pas ce qui
se passait c'est pas possible quand on
vit quasiment un mois les uns avec les
autres quand quand on organise un
événement quand on passe de ville en
ville quand on suit des gens quand on
vit 24 quasiment 24 sur 24 ce qu'on
appelle la caravane du Tour le Tour de
France avec les équipes et CEA c'est pas
possible qu'à un moment donné depuis
tant d'années les organisateurs n'ai pas
été au courant de ce qui se passait
c'est pas
concevable là il y a une responsabilité
aussi je crois qu'il faut que tout le
monde soit responsable c'est trop facile
de dire moi j'organise un événement ce
qui se passe dedans s'il y a des gens
qui trichent et cetera ah ben je lui
enlève son titre je lui enlève c'estes
c'estes ses gains et cetera c'est un peu
je trouve hein c'est un peu facile je
pense que il faut responsabiliser un peu
plus les organisateurs les obliger
eux-mêmes à faire la loi mais à la faire
vraiment on les incite mais je trouve
pas suffisamment pas suffisamment
parce
que ça va peut-être vous faire rire mais
Coluche le disait lui-même c'est un peu
vrai qui fait qui fait le parcours du
Tour de France par exemple je cite le
sance qui fait le parcours à un moment
donné voilà c'est cette dureté de
l'effort la dureté du parcours la dureté
de l'événement le spectacle le spectacle
qui fait vendre un journal le spectacle
qui fait vendre des droits des droits
télé et cetera et cetera C ce mod éconi
là qui un moment
donné vis-à-vis des hommes qui concour à
cet événement je dirais pas les oblige
mais c'est voilà c'est une mécanique
dans lequelle tout le monde voilà
s'inscrit un moment donné le résultat ça
sur types qui sont sur assis sur une
selle et qui se DOP pour assurer le
spectacle pour gagner pour gagner à
titre personnel c'est vrai mais pour que
le spectacle soit là aussi faut pas êre
hypocrite c'est la
vérité
et ça je je donne l'exemple je focalise
pas sur le vélo je je cite parce que
c'est criant mais sur toute les tous les
organisateurs il faut je pense dans
l'avenir que les organisateurs prennent
leur part de responsabilité et qu'il
soient eux-mêmes aussi concernés
lorsqu'il y a des des tricheries
oui qualité de ministre est-ce que vous
pensez qu'il y a assez de contrôle
inopiné
en fait je pens là au jour d'aujourd'hui
oui je crois que oui la vérité c'est que
et pourquoi on a élargi les compétences
de la FLD c'était pour qu'elle se
rapproche le plus possible
des des professionnel de de de de de la
de la répression enfin je veux des
policiers des pour que on puisse faire
des contrôle beaucoup plus ciblé et
beaucoup plus efficace voilà ça sert à
rien de ventiler de manière ère
anarchique des contrôles en sachant que
bon alors ce milieu n'est pas touché ce
milieu n'est pas touché mais on en fait
quand même bon ça coûte tellement cher
que il faut enfin pour moi il faut faire
des frappes chirurgicales dans des chez
des athlètes ou dans des sports qui sont
assez assez suspicieux voilà euh donc je
crois beaucoup à la à la à la connexion
et à l'interaction entre tous ceux qui
luttent contre ce fléo pour que on aille
chercher vraiment euh les choses là où
il faut je fais une petite parenthèse
attention parce que certains athlètes
notamment dans le nouveau système où des
des contrôleurs vont chercher les
athlètes chez eux le matin et cetera et
CETA faut faire attention parce qu'il y
a des excès de Zè aussi il m remonter
souvent milieux sportif et des athlètes
en particulier des gens et des
contrôleurs je je l'ai dit au au patron
les FLD lorsque j'étais
ministre des gens qui parce que céit cri
sur leurs feuill leur règlement tape TR
fois 1 2 3 à la porte du contrôler le
matin à
6h le temps que le type se lève ou
entendre même les trois coups à une
porte c'est déjà presque un miracle à
cet Hel parce que les athlètes dorment
en général ils ont besoin de sommeil
surtout à 6h du matin et le type est au
fond du couloir l'athlète ouvre et c'est
quoi alors contrôle mais voilà je tapis
tris fois vous avez pas ouvert jeis au
fond du couloir c'est un non chaud c'est
arrivé voilà donc faut il faut aussi
faire attention à ce
que à ce qu'on
fait justement monsieur le ministre sur
ces contrôles donc il y a la à la
Direction des Sports un bureau qui est
chargé de la prévention du
dopage est-ce que c'est lui qui donne
des des orientations aux directions
régionales qu'on appelle maintenant
jeunesse sport cohésion
sociale normalement non mais tout le
monde me se parle tout le monde se
connaît c'est un petit milieu et moi je
crois beaucoup plus aux hommes plutôt
que au aux instances les instances sont
là pour cadrer les choses et cetera mais
honnêtement la qualité des hommes tant à
la FLD comm ministère des Sports que au
sein de l'laesp et cetera et cetera fait
que ce sont des gens intelligents qui
essaie de donner le meilleur deeux
même d'essayer d'être le plus
constructif possible et le plus efficace
possible voilà et d'avoir le le plus de
communication entre eux parce qu'ils
savent que ils ont le même objectif en
réalité et ça fonctionne je trouve que
ça fonctionne voilà pour ça qu'on peut
élargir encore les choses mais la
prochaine strate je pour moi je vous le
dis elle est de mutualiser on pourrait
le faire en France qu'on a l'argel en
France on pourrait mutualiser avec
l'argel par
exemple hein l'Agence de Régulation des
Jeux paril sportif en Lig on pourrait
avoir qu'une seule et même entité et il
faut faut qu'on la crée à l'échelle du
monde et qu'on soit précurseur sur ce
sujet voilà pour permettre à des pays
qui sont très laxistes sur le sujet et
bien de se doter parce que beaucoup
l'ont pas encore fait de se doter de
lois euh pour c'est pas unors sujet que
je fais hein je vous parle de de loi sur
la corruption sportive pour moi la
corruption sportive est dans le même
état d'esprit qu'une tricherie au titre
d'une performance c'est exactement la
même chose c'est un dopage qui est
différent hein mais c'est c'est le même
moteur c'est la même chose c'est la même
mécanique d'ailleurs c'est les mêmes
Mafi je vous le répète donc il y a
beaucoup de pays qui se sont pas encore
dotés de lois pour lutter contre la
corruption sportive
ils sont dotés de certains de certaines
choses sur le dopage mais c'est pas
suffisamment puissant pas suffisamment
fort ils sont pas aussi la France est
assez précurseur sur ce sujets et c'est
bien c'est bien
donc continuons à le faire parce que
franchement je pense honnêtement même si
l'industrie pharmaceutique continuera à
avoir de l'avance et cetera
naturellement je pense que la lutte
fonctionne j'en ai entendu j'en ai lu
certains qui disaient le contraire qu'il
faut légaliser le dopage je suis
totalement contre contre à 100 pour vous
vous rendez compte de l'image qu'onon
adressera à notre jeunesse de réussir en
trichant mais c'est quoi cette histoire
c'est impossible c'est alors là on
atteint un niveau
philosophique dire la compétition n'a
d'intérêt que lorsqu'elle est compliquée
et difficile sinon ce n'est pas la
compétition ça n'a pas de sens ça n'a
aucun sens
ENF le plaisir de la compétition le
plaisir le cette saveur compliqué à
décrire avec des mots hein mais en tout
cas la difficulté de gagner réside dans
cela si ça devient facile si pour
arriver à une destination on a forcément
une autoroute large ça n'a aucun intérêt
zéro donc et et ça c'est un message de
vie he c'est un message de de de de de
philosophie de vie donc demain et
certains étudiants le font pour passer
des examens et ben on prend des
cachetons on se dope on triche par
rapport à celui qui le fait pas aussi il
y a pas de contrôle bon mais dans la vie
aussi il y en a plein qui trichent dans
différents domaines pour aller plus vite
pour hein voilà donc c'est c'est c'est
la même c'est la c'est la même chose he
on est dans les mêmes si on pouvait
localiser dans le cerveau de l'homme
l'endroit où va se dérouler l'envie de
tricher bah c'est le même endroit je
vous assure ça je pas besoin de faire un
scanner pour ça c'est clair donc ce ce
ce cette
cette tentation qu'on aurait de dire
légalisons le le
dopage légalisons la
triche je vais je vais élargir un peu
légalisons le légalisons la drogue
légalisons le le cannabis par exemple
quand quand on entend des médecins il y
en avait un à ma place il y a peu de
temps mais parce que moi j'étais naïf
sur le sujet je parlais de drogue dou
ces personnes non non non non non ça
c'est ça c'était les les euh les pétards
de vos parents oui c'était de la drogue
12 maintenant le taux de TH actuel dans
la résine de cannabis il est X fois
supérieur et nous sommes dans des des en
tout cas des des conséquences enfin des
des de drogue dur c'est une drogue dure
maintenant donc arrêtez de dire parler
de drogue dou ça nexiste plus voilà donc
c'est un message dans une société
euh qui qui qui faut faut faut pas
lâcher l'affaire quoi parce qu'il s'agit
de la santé des gens voilà on protège
les gens contre l'ambante on protège les
gens contre la cigarette contre l'alcool
et cetera faut protéger évidemment les
gens
sur la problématique du
dopage merci je vais demander au
président Carl s'il veut bien intervenir
oui merci monsieur le Président en vous
priant de bien vouloir m'excuser d'avoir
pu assister au début de l'audition mais
il y avait un débat important en séance
vous avez dit monsieur le ministre à
juste titre qu'il fallait pas focaliser
sur le cyclisme en matière de dopage je
pense que vous avez parfaitement raison
et mais vous avez dit aussi qu'il y
avait des sports qui étaient pour
reprendre vos termes assez suspicieux
alors là aussi sans vouloir les
stigmatiser sans vouloir les montrer du
droit quels sont ces sports qui seraient
plus j'allais dire touchés par par par
le dopage c'est pas très compliqué il
s'agit de tous les sports qui sont durs
voilà euh quand je dis ENF bon est-ce
qu'il y a un sport facile un sport dur
physiquement physiquement voilà euh dans
lequel on
peut
augmenter
artificiellement les capacités physiques
voilà euh donc
voilà ça se voit à l'œil je des
sports je suis pas je suis pas sûr et
encore c'est pas vrai parce que on peut
parler des betabolcan euh euh dans sport
de de de de précisionin on sait que
voilà on peut on peut se doper grâce au
même l'alcool est un est un je sais pas
si vous le savez dans tous les dans
toutes les disciplines de tir l'alcool
est un produit de Pan enfin considéré
comme un produit de Pan parce qu'elle
élimine le le trembl le tremblement
naturel que nous avons tous hein voilà à
une certaine dose hein forcément
évidemment mais en tout cas voilà
euh euh mais tout ce qui permet euh tout
ce qui permet euh
d'améliorer ou de stabiliser un effet
naturel voilà tout ce qui n'est pas
alors où commence et où se termin ça
c'est la grande question est-ce que
est-ce que ça commence à la vitamine C
qu'on peut prendre le matin voilà voilà
où s'arrête les choses moi j'aurais
tendance à penser
que
lorsque lorsqu'il y a vraiment de
manière significative un change
physique
physiologique extrêmement net qui soit
visuel en terme de
d'efficacité ben là on est on est on
passe la frontière du dopage
voilà ce sont
des des sujets qui doivent être
appréendés le plus tôt possible voilà et
c'est le travail des fédérations si on
veut amélior ces choses il faut que dans
le le cycle de
formation de de de tous ceux qui vont
enseigner que ce soit au sein d'
fédération ou même à l'école et bien on
est on est une sensibilisation sur C
sujet mais plus forte qu'elle n'existe
aujourd'hui elle est quasiment in
existante en réalité voilà à l'époque
lorsque j'étais
athlète je faisais
un certain nombre d'interventions dans
les collèges dans mon département
d'origine et euh j'y avais associé
c'était quelque chose qui fonctionnait
très très
bien j'y avais associé deux choses je
disais la chose suivante je disais c'est
euh le dopage dans le
sport c'est une tricherie vis-à-vis de
la concurrence par rapport à la dureté
de la
concurrence est-ce que la drogue
dans la société civile qui résulte des
mêmes conséquences pour l'individu hein
et qui peut aller jusqu'à la mort n'est
pas en réalité une tricherie vis-à-vis
de la dureté de la
vie un échappatoire j'esquive la
difficulté voilà j'avais j'avais mêlé
ces deux
fléau vis-à-vis des collégiens et je
vous assure qu'il comprenent bien les
choses mais très bien je partais de
l'exemple du sport et de la tentation
à en expliquant ce qu'est la la ce que
je vous disis tout à l'heure la beauté
de réussir dans la difficulté quelque
part et puis l'intérêt euh par rapport
aussi à ce qui peut les toucher ce qui
peut-être les touchit déjà euh le le la
drogue dans dans leur vie de de
collégien et ça fonctionnait bien je
pense que ces sujets pourraient être
liés dans une une
une campagne de
prévention tout cas vis-à-vis des jeunes
avec des HES sportifs et civil et euh
monsieur ministre on constate quand même
que dans cette lutte antidopage y
compris dans le domaine de la prévention
je dirais même surtout dans le domaine
de la prévention il y a des fédérations
qui sont plus engagées que d'autres plus
impliquées que d'autres plus
volontaristes que d'autres pourquoi à
vos yeux est-ce que c'est uniquement un
problème de moyens financiers de volonté
politique ok pense pas c'est
honnêtement il en tient la qualité des
personnes qui dirigent C mêmees
fédération voilà tout simplement des
individus qui n'y pensent peut-être pas
pas suffisamment ou qui se disent bon
mon sport il y a pas eu de cas il y a
pas eu de problème
donc voilà donc je pense pas qu'il a
besoin d'en faire plus ça va me coûter
des sous je préfère mettre des moyens
sur le fait d'aider mes club pour qu'il
puisse être les plus attrayants
possiblees à la rentrée scolaire par
exemple bon voilà
euh en
revanche je pense que
cette vis-à-vis des des des fédérations
le le le com le commune pardon le Comité
national olympique le
CNOSF devrait être aussi moteur sur ces
sujets hein il est quand même celui qui
héberge toutes nos fédérations
olympiques et bon nombre de d'autres
fédérations voilà donc ça ça pourrait
être aussi pour
eux pour cette famille du sport cette
famille de
l'olympisme un un domaine dans lequel il
devrait être je pense à mon avis un peu
plus moteur voilà beaucoup plus moteur
beaucoup plus moteur voilà parce que à
travers ces ces sujets extrêmement
négatifs on touche des valeurs
d'éducation
on touche des valeurs d'éducation
vis-à-vis de nos enfants
voilà on ne réussit pas que grâce à le
fait de B je je je dis à titre personnel
mais ce que nous montre
malheureusement notre télévision
d'aujourd'hui où on voit des gens se
retrouver dans un espèce de bocal
pendant des semaines et devenir des
stars sans avoir rien fait si simplement
manger dormir et essayer de parler pour
certains d'entre eux c'est B c'est juste
surréaliste la vie n'est c'est pas ça
voilà donc et oui je voilà
oui mais c'est un raccourci le dopage
c'est un raccourci ça c'est un autre
raccourci ce sont des valeurs qui
vis-à-vis de nos enfants euh si on n'
pas des parents solides ou un système
éducatif solide ou peut-être des
fédérations sportifes pour ceux qui ont
la chance de faire un sport et bien ce
sont des valeurs qui leur échappent et
un jour ces enfants là vont se retrouver
dans la vie tous les jours en se disant
mais attends il faut que je fasse quoi
pour réussir ma vie parce que ce que
j'ai vu à la télé les exemples que j'ai
pu voir ça marche
pas j'élargis les choses mais c'est le
paix de prévention il va loin quoiin et
si à travers le sport on peut rattraper
rattraper ne serait-ce que on a 150000
ou 160000 élèves qui sortent du système
éducatif en fin de 3e sans rien on le
sait chaque année si grâce à des actions
de prévention je m'écarte un peu du
sujet mais en tout cas de prévention qui
qui qui donne ces valeurs là ou qui
indique les mauvais chemins versus les
bons chemins et bien peut-être qu'on en
aura un petit peu moins de ces 150 ou
160000 gamins chaque année se retrouve
dans la vie sans rien du tout et surtout
sans envie sans
rêve souhaitez-vous monsieur le ministre
ajouter quelque chose sinon euh ben
j'espère que vous allez euh réussir dans
votre dans votre quête et si vous avez
besoin à nouveau de de mes services
d'une manière ou d'une autre vous pouvez
compter sur moi voilà
et je pense que il faut aller il faut
taper fort voilà je le redis je reviens
sur ce que j'ai dit au début il faut
taper fort pour réussir à prot à
protéger les gens contre contre
eux-mêmees voilà faut pas hésiter que ce
soit les athlètes ceux qui font partie
des des réseaux de Deal ceux qui
organisent les compétitions il faut que
tout le monde prenne ses responsabilités
et les assume donc s'il faut faire des
lois pour ça et ben faites-les et
faisons-les je serai de tout cœur avec
vous merci beaucoup je
vais après vous avoir à nouveau
remercier en ayant bien enregistré que
si besoin était nous pourrions faire
appel à vous à nouveau je demande à mes
collègues de ne pas partir tout de suite
vous êtes libre bien sûr vous monsieur
le ministre merci je dois leur
communiquer un ordre du jour pour la
semaine prochaine
merci voilà pour les auditions de Michel
Boyon l'ancien président de l'Agence
française de lutte contre le dopage de
David douiller médaillux olympique et
ancien ministre des sports ainsi que de
Jean-Pierre monddenard médecin du sport
et spécialiste de la question du dopage
ils étaient entendus par la commission
d'enquête sur la lutte contre le dopage
récemment créé pour apprécier
l'efficacité de la politique de lutte
contre le dopage vous pourrez évidemment
revoir ces auditions à tout instant sur
notre site s
publicsena.fr très bonne journée à tous
sur notre
chaîne